speaking at a political
conference former national security
adviser to the president of the united
states michael flynn
was asked about a myanmar-style coup
happening in the u.s
why couldn't it happen he says there's
nothing stopping it and it should happen
which the best way i can see it is him
calling for a military coup
saying it should happen here in the
united states those that aren't familiar
there was there were claims of election
fraud by the military in myanmar
so they intervened and uh people started
clapping and cheering for this and it's
worrying because
i look i often say this it doesn't
matter what you personally what
what i personally believe or what anyone
really personally believes it matters
what the factions believe and how many
there are
because there are people that completely
agree with michael flynn there are
people that completely disagree
and we're not going to persuade them so
this is it i mean the fracture is here
and it's going to get uh i don't know i
think i think the escalation is gonna
get
worrisome as it is we've got a bunch of
stories about riots
portland seems to be on fire every day
anyway and so we're gonna be hanging out
and uh spending this memorial day with
retired green beret joe kent who's
running for office as an america first
candidate in washington's third district
i believe correct that's right
just north of portland yep in the in the
this is the battleground right
literally yeah do you wanna just give a
brief introduction to who you are what
you do
sure absolutely uh joe kent i was in the
army for a little bit over 20 years
um it was a green beret started out as
an enlisted guy in ranger regiment
worked my way into special forces
so i joined just before 9 11. i was kind
of born and raised actually in portland
oregon itself
and portland was much different 20 plus
years ago than it is today
so enlisted in the army in 98
and then was in special operations
already when 9 11 happened and so that
kind of
set the next you know 15 16 years of my
life on the
on the war path literally so i spent a
good deal of time overseas primarily in
iraq
uh some time in yemen and some time in
africa as well
uh retired and then went into a uh
working in the cia for about
about a year and then had to resign
after my late wife was
was killed herself in syria so she was a
in the military she was a navy uh
cryptological officer
working uh with special operations so
she was killed uh
about a month after trump tried to get
our troops out of syria the first time
so that kind of propelled me into the
the political realm despite all the
grief i was going through
i i strongly supported president trump's
uh foreign policy
especially getting us out of the endless
wars we had to go defeat the territorial
caliphate to take away
the ground that isis controlled because
the existential threat they prep
posed to the rest of the world but once
that was done we had to get out as soon
as possible because there's nothing for
us in that area so
the way that the permanent ruling class
and the government turned against trump
and the way the media got him lockstep
to like paint it like trump didn't know
what he was doing he was just this big
savage
careless man who was gonna pretty much
upset the world liberal in the
the liberal world order by ending a war
that really inspired me to start
speaking out
it's uh it's memorial day i would say
i think people but i'm gonna say i know
people don't know or care about what
today is like we saw with camel hair
it's a long weekend but uh
i sincerely mean it man thanks for for
everything you did thanks for serving
and
for your sacrifices and to your your
wife for
you know what she was what she did for
this country and what she did to end
i mean just the atrocities like it like
you said man
isis was as bad as it gets and there's a
lot of things that the united states has
done which has contributed to
the expansion of extremists we've had
some pretty bad presidents
which is why i think talking with you
about america first would be uh is going
to be great
i mean i was giving an example like the
fast and furious program
which gives guns to cartels we gotta we
gotta do something about this man we
gotta stop this stuff but uh
sincerely man thank you memorial day i
mean thanks for being here so we're
gonna we'll we'll get into all this
stuff it's gonna be a good conversation
we got
ian hello everyone ian crossland over
here good to see you joe
thank you more about your uh your
experience the last
couple decades yeah it's gonna be good
lydia in the corner pushing buttons i'm
decked out very patriotically i
intentionally wore red white and blue
today i was feeling very
um patriotic so hopefully this will be a
good conversation i'm really excited
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member
to get access to our exclusive members
area just click the big blue members
only button you can sign up
and we're gonna have a bonus segment
later tonight around 11 pm is usually
when it goes up
when you become a member you are helping
us expand the company it's you know
we're not going to go on by ferraris
we're going to use your membership
the money that comes in we're using it
to fund this work we're using it to
expand
we want to hire more journalists we want
to create better shows we want to build
culture
and that's what you do so it's
supporting the cause it's
supporting our this company here and
what we do but
if you really do like the show and you
really care about these kind of
conversations then please
share the link to this video click the
url click share do whatever you got to
do
because we don't have the marketing
budget of these big media companies it's
just you guys
you guys be the marketing branch and
then people can hear these conversations
and maybe
some people will learn about what
memorial day means so uh without further
ado let's just
we'll just we'll just jump right into it
and um i'll just i'll just ask you man
let's just start talking about your your
campaign you're running for you're
running as a republican but you're
running as an america first
candidate what is that what does that
mean so america first i'm running
against a
sitting republican jamie hura butler she
voted for the impeachment of president
trump that was kind of the straw that
broke the camel's back but prior to that
she had been a pretty
horrible representative and pretty
horrible republican as well so she voted
to withdraw the funding to construct the
border wall the additional emergency
funding that president trump was using
to secure our southern border
she voted in support of obamacare she
voted for the war she voted to keep our
troops in syria
she went along with the whole russian
bounties afghanistan lie from last year
so in every sense of the form she is
exactly what we need to get rid of in
washington a career politician
a democrat a democrat exactly yeah a
democrat so it's the weirdest thing to
me i mean yeah
why would someone run as a republican
but clearly be a democrat
i think she just had blind hatred of
trump she's been very
outspoken about that in 2016 she said
that she penciled then paul ryan because
she couldn't vote for president trump
and then she kind of got quiet when
trump started to actually make progress
but then every key time that she could
have stood stood strong and actually
worked in the congress to push through
some of president trump's key agenda
items
that he was elected by the american
people for and that she wrote his
coattails into office on
she folded every single time she felt
the old dc
mainstream media lincoln project
narrative because it's easier to do i
think
in dc when you're disconnected from your
people it's much easier just to
fall in with what the mainstream media
pushes you so you're a
is it fair to say you're an anti-work on
a guy i am yeah absolutely i mean i am
not a
isolationist i think we need to have a
robust strong military we need to have
robust uh intelligence capabilities
throughout the world to keep us
aware of what's going on so we can
eliminate threats before they become
a you know a major crisis but these
endless wars the way that we have
really gone and done regime change wars
and then not course corrected the times
where we've
really messed up which has been the
entire global war on terror um
i'm very much against those what was it
like like how did you
kind of i don't have rectifiers how did
you come to grips in terms of
personally like serving over there and
thinking about that that yeah maybe you
were there
or that the us was there for nefarious
purposes i don't know how you think
about it
yeah um i i think at uh well
when i first joined the military i just
wanted to go fight for my country you
know very young patriotic seeing the
1993 blackhawk down moment when i was
13.
that that was pretty key in my life
because you know it was the first time i
think we saw like brutal combat actually
on tv
like the gulf war there was some
television going on then but actually
seeing in 93 cnn
uh filming american soldiers getting
drunk through the streets i was just
like wow there's guys over fighting
real evil and we're back here in the
states just kind of hanging out so i
want to go do that so
and then 9 11 happened i'd already been
in the military for a couple years and
so we just trained and trained and
trained and hoped that we would someday
get our shot because that's what you
want to do when you're in the military
you want to go fight for your country
so after 9 11 we thought that we had the
most righteous mission ever
um but we quickly pivoted from that so
for pretty much from the time that bin
laden and crew
ran into pakistan i mean george bush
even said in april of 2002 that we
changed our mission to nation building
and we
we're going to build these democracies
in afghanistan and the next thing you
know they're like guys we've got to
invade iraq and then they made up all
that
intelligence so by the time i got into
war
um in iraq i was eager to be there
but i i thought that someone above my
level
knew more than me so the first time i
went to war i was i was 23 years old i
was a sergeant
green beret we were tasked with either
going out and
finding or arresting members of al qaeda
or saddam's regime
and then we got tasked with a classic
green beret mission which is to
build militaries out of local forces so
we took a bunch of the anti-saddam
militias and we started to turn them
into the iraqi security forces when i
was going through some of the rosters of
these militiamen
a lot of them had huge ties to iran
their iranian fund
funded militias and then i was like this
doesn't seem like a good idea because
iran pretty much hates our guts too you
know
knowing just the history of iran and our
dealings with them
so but you know in the back of my head i
was like surely somebody knows more than
me there's like generals somewhere that
have a plan did you know the history of
afghanistan and the mujahideen yes and
all that so i mean at a certain point
you're like wait a minute wait a second
yeah
i mean what are they doing you put some
faith and you think that there's
somebody behind the curtain at oz
um and then just watching how we just
continued to double and triple down on
failure like when
i was in iraq when they they gave the
order to disband the iraqi
uh government and the iraqi military and
say that all these guys that were
associated with the bath party
couldn't have jobs and all of us that
were on their on the ground level we
were like this is a terrible idea this
would be like going to
my the town that my military base is in
and saying hey guys you don't have jobs
anymore we're not paying you next month
and the government pretty much hates you
and we're coming after you
but leaving us the keys to the armory i
mean
how do you think that's gonna go that's
basically what we did in iraq so
i just saw the narrative slowly get
chipped away based on what i was seeing
in the ground
um and then what was it was it contracts
the the big companies were
we're getting money like why stay in
there why why did it become
okay we're not after is you know bin
laden anymore it's nation-building
i think a ton of it was hubris i mean
just really at the at the highest levels
i mean
people in the bush administration they
really believe that neoconservative
ideology
that if we went over especially in a
place like iraq because it's centrally
located
it does have the potential to be
independent and to be successful and
really thrive
because it looks good on paper they
thought hey if we just apply enough good
old american
force and a good old american can do
like these guys are just going to be
like well thanks america let's have an
election
and yeah democracy just kicks in it just
kicks in we'll be your best friends
we'll cut you a great oil deal next
thing you know
you know no but none of that actually
works so i think people they just
doubled and tripled down
on that idea because they were
embarrassed and the the bipartisan
effort that the iraq war was going back
to
our current president joe biden who was
the head of the senate foreign relations
committee at the time
there was bipartisan lying that went on
to the american people so then there
became this bipartisan game of like hey
we're all kind of part of this and then
the folks at the top levels of the
military anybody who disagreed with the
way the
invasion went they got fired and so all
the yes men got promoted and they just
said hey we can
we can make this work and a lot of them
i think probably had the best of
intentions they were like hey if the us
government's going to put this all on
our shoulders as the military
we will do the best that we we can but
at the end of the day if you tell the
military to go do stuff they're just
going to apply military
tactics how long were you in iraq
so i have about five years total on the
ground i was there pretty much
every year of the war minus 2010 and
then i went back again
for a withdraw on 11 and i went back
again in the counter isis fight in 16.
that's
that's that's the next question i was
going to have for you is you know you
went back to fight isis
your wife did as well uh so this is this
is a really different
kind of mission i guess so after you saw
everything with the nation building what
was it like when
you know isis was was picking up these
people uh
like the caliphate was was was truly
horrifying what these people were doing
did you have a different vision of it
like all of a sudden now like this one
matters
well yeah i mean a lot of it too was i
told you so
uh not just me but a lot of us that were
that had boots on the ground and and
when i was there in 2011 by by that time
we had pretty much handed the entire
government over to the iranians the
iranians did a really good job with
infiltrating the government
of iraq so much to the point that uh
iranian generals like qasim solmani felt
very safe running around
iraq because they knew that we didn't
have the actual political will to take
them off the battlefield
iran saw that they could kill american
soldiers under bush under obama and that
we wouldn't do anything
and so they felt emboldened when we left
the country they completely and totally
took it over but when they
as they were doing that they were
disenfranchising which is to put it
mildly the entire sunni population so
especially when the syrian civil war
broke out and assad was fighting the
sunnis you could just break it down
geographically as long as there were
sunnis in between
the area just to the west of baghdad
and just to the east of damascus getting
pushed by these two iranian shia forces
you had an absolute civil war so the
only means of recourse
for these sunnis was isis or al-qaeda or
some form of
sunni extremists so really it
the evolution of isis is was pretty much
born the day that we
invaded iraq and then disbanded the
iraqi military and then it's it's really
fascinating how
you know under obama i mean it grows yep
couldn't really do anything to stop it
but uh trump just wiped it out
right yeah i was there i was there in 16
under obama and the rules it was
most deployments in the obama era were
we have to be deployed
because obama doesn't want to pull us
out because he'll look weak but we also
really don't want to fight
you know the latter part of bush was
that way too bush was just done probably
like around i don't know 06 or 07 he was
just like i'm riding this out and you
guys are over there
and i'll leave it to the next guy to
include negotiating deals for the status
of forces but
obama those those last years it was the
same thing he just he had called isis
the jv team
early on and then after that he just did
not want to deal with it
do you think that uh obama wanted isis
because it was causing problems for
assad and we wanted we wanted assad out
so
let isis have adam and then we'll come
and clean up we'll sweep it up and take
it once it's done
there was definitely people in his
security team in his national security
establishment that i think did want that
they
very much wanted another war in syria
and i think a lot of them are still in
the government right now
so i think that permanent ruling class
of neoconservatives and neo-liberals who
you know they they say different things
to justify their wars but the end
the end state is always more invasions
more occupations
i i think those guys are pulling pulling
the strings from behind the scenes
so i've had a lot of conversations with
people about trump the abraham and
abraham accords and the conflict and uh
you know on the service i think the
abraham accords did a lot of good uh
normalized trade between a lot of
countries and israel but we've we've had
people say
it was nothing you know it was just like
these countries were already working
together i disagree with that
i really do think that when it comes to
the israel-palestine issue people are
very tribal and just
hate one side or the other and i'm like
look i think trump was america first all
the way
he didn't want to be involved in any of
this he didn't care about what it was he
said what do we do to get to end it i'm
done let's get out why are we here
absolutely
so we actually had um i think scott
horton told us this right where he said
within the first three months trump
ordered a full withdrawal from from
afghanistan he like he gets in offices
get ready get him out we're done
yeah and they stopped him they said no
yep they blocked him and then
we get four years of trump and then it
never happened yeah
i mean it's just that there is that
class there in the pentagon the national
security establishment that they are
i think a lot of them and i understand
this and this has kind of been my
my story of my trajectory throughout my
career
i felt that we needed to continue to
stay over there i felt compelled
that hey we need to keep going over and
fighting because we've lost so much
especially if you're in a leadership
position you're like we lost these guys
in this last deployment
we've got to go back over and we got to
make it right and i don't i don't just
mean like revenge but we got to go get
something we've given so much we've got
to get something out of this i want to
make it work
and i think there is a lot of that but i
do think there's also a lot of
but then that quickly can shift into
pride into hubris really fast when a
civilian civilian leadership comes in
and says hey military guys like this
isn't working what are you doing
it's like screw you i've been fighting
and dying like what do you mean it isn't
working
so i think that's but there is also a
lot of money tied up into that and a lot
of careers and there's been this whole
machinery made to keep us
at war what's that thing called where um
you know people will invest in something
like that sunk costs sunk costs yeah
yeah fallacy
yeah and the gamblers fallacy they keep
putting more and saying no no now is
that
i already put in a million i'm not going
to lose it i'll just put it another
we'll get out we'll get out we'll take
ourselves out of this hole and it's like
at a certain point man you got to be
honest with yourself at some point i
mean i really wish that i
could come here and say hey i served for
for 20 years and in the five years i
have on the ground in iraq like i built
this thing and it worked and we
we made the world a better place i wish
i could say that but at the end of the
day
our job is to win and our job is to do
the best that we can for our country and
if we're not being honest
and saying at like the halfway point of
trying plan a that like hey man plan a
sucks it was my idea my bad let's learn
from that and let's shift to something
else but we
the government is terrible at that
political agendas but then also i mean
the military
the occupation mindset and the
occupation machinery it is very
lucrative
so now you're uh you you said you grew
up in portland
i did yeah you're running for office in
washington which is the district just
north of the portland area
yep uh you're you're back from middle
east conflict you've seen
the the good the bad what's your plan
what do you want to do for america
so plan right now is the america first
agenda and the america first agenda
to me is taking everything that we are
blessed with here
in america and producing what we can
for our people to secure our country so
a big problem that we have right now i
think in america
is our deficit spending like we're
running the national debt
through the roof and that's not just
fiscally bad i think
for a while we've been able to get away
with that because america produced
things
and america was actually a place where
we invented and produced things
we've killed off that entire part of our
country under the
banner of either on the right right wing
folks are just like hey whatever the
market will bear free market man
if we if it's better for the market to
ship all of our jobs overseas
then it's fine because we get more
access to cheap crap at walmart
and it isn't that a great economy and
then the lefties come in and they say
hey
no we can't drill for oil because it's
bad for the environment we can't cut
down trees because that's bad for the
environment now we're in this position
where we don't produce anything
and china and then all the gold from
rich japan all these other countries
they're eventually going to stop buying
our debt bonds and what happens when
they stop buying our debt bonds
and if you're china and you have
malicious intent towards america to put
it mildly
you stopped buying our debt bonds you
could crash our currency i mean yep
yes that could make 08 look like a
there's been there's been concern about
the belt and road initiative
because oh yeah china is basically you
know we we send them petrodollar because
we want them to use and support our
system but then they just use it to fund
the expansion of
you know the their trade routes and
their factories but they earn allegiance
from other countries using the money
we're giving them
so we've created this kind of downward
spiral for america yep
i i wonder if if the crash off you know
is is inevitable the the u.s
reserve currency will eventually just
not it won't be the reserve currency any
more than us dollar
and there's already a lot of people
saying that for the past several years
it's
been the case you know russia and china
have done been dumping dollars they
don't they're not as concerned they're
preparing for a shift
and so if we don't get on track like
with what trump was doing bringing the
factories back securing our borders
getting people in america producing and
working yep then when that happens
it's going to be worse as you said worse
than a weight probably worse than the
great depression
but if we bring our factories back
secure our borders that's right start
producing again when that happens we'll
be all right
yeah no that's exactly it so all these
everything that we just discussed i
think sometimes gets dismissed as oh
that's just an economic issue it's not
it's a national security
issue i think we need to be on a war
footing with returning production back
to our country
so deregulating a lot of these
industries that have been gutted by over
regulation in my district
heart timber and heart of timber country
and that that whole industry has been
gutted over the last couple decades
under the guise of environmentalism
we've just let these forests absolutely
faster we've killed off a very lucrative
logging industry so i want to
start there and start restoring that
industry so that we can actually
have people stay in our state graduate
high school they don't have to go to
college take a bunch of student loan
debt
live in their town and support a family
off of one income i
that was the american dream for a long
time we've been told by the media and
the left that those days are over you
can't have that
you need to get a get a college degree
at any cost even if you
take a whole bunch of college debt and
then when you know i'd say
from gen x on once we took on the
college debt and we got we moved to a
big city
half of those jobs have either been
shipped overseas because they are tech
jobs or we've had legal immigration come
in with the h1b visa system and one visa
system
and absolutely undercut those as well
can we do that sustainably the
timbering yes absolutely we totally can
um
so what is it what does that mean for
you you've probably got a lot of
environmentalists being like this guy
wants to come in and chop down our
forest right exactly
yeah so we have to have the government
control all the forests no i mean it is
it is in the best interest of the
companies that would go
and harvest the timber to do it
responsibly
you know it's not in their best interest
whatsoever to go and just clear-cut
acreage after acreage i mean they've
these families these these timber
giants they've been doing this stuff for
quite a while and there's a way to do it
and there's a rule for the government
but i don't think the federal government
there's a role for the state government
and the local government
to have some sort of checks and balances
in there so if you did get a bad actor
he's like ah-ha i'm going to go
clear-cut all these foreign they'll
never catch me you know
that we do have a the mechanism to stop
them but having the federal government
control
half of our state land is just
ridiculous i think back to 2016 watching
hillary versus trump
and you know it really felt to me like
we were at this
we were entering this really dangerous
period where the u.s
the u.s superiority was being threatened
are we we are the superpower we control
so much around the world military bases
everywhere
and one thing that we say too much on
this show is thucydides trap
which is as a rising economic power
supplants the dominant there's
a war that breaks out so i think about
2016 and it seemed like hillary
clinton's mentality was
we will not stop we like we are facing
this this this threat to the united
states and we will blow up whoever we
have to to maintain
our position so when she when she was
questioned about a no-fly zone over
syria
and and she was warned that would lead
to war with russia she said she didn't
care she was like
so what well you'll go to war with
russia it has to be done
trump said why do we want to go to war
with russia right we want to do that we
want to come back and make america great
yeah so i've i viewed trump as someone
who was saying listen we shouldn't be
doing these things
the crash if it hits us we need to be
prepared for it yes
and if we keep looking externally to
just forcing our way to try and maintain
this rickety system
we're gonna we're gonna have that long
fall we're not gonna have the ability to
produce medicine which we saw with covid
yeah it's it's remarkable that when
we're in this mass pandemic no vitamin c
china makes it massive china makes it
yeah antibiotics china makes it
yeah that to me was really incredible
yeah i mean just look at the lesson that
we learned from the masks right there
alone that should have been a wake-up
call okay it was masks and it turned out
that it really wasn't that big of a deal
but what if that was something
absolutely essential i mean it was
vitamin c yeah vitamin c and china's
just like hey we don't have it or you're
done or or if they want to be a bad
actor about it so
i mean i think the best thing that we
could do for our national security is
bring back our industry and our
production you know and energy is a huge
one we saw what happened when biden
turned off the keystone xl pipeline
you know and now gas prices rise i mean
hillary hillary would complain all day
and want to go
potentially getting wars of syria over
strategically worthless land
like or with wars of russia to get into
a fight over syria
but at the same time she lets syria or
sorry she lets russia
have become an oil giant if we if we put
u.s oil back on the market
all those prices go down and russia has
less money it starts to make sense now
with syria they want to run that
pipeline the gas pipeline yes
with with russia the u.s shuts down the
keystone pipeline the u.s
you know then the colonial hack happens
we have all these problems
then governor gretchen whitmer says she
wants to shut down this pipeline yeah
well when you think about it maybe the
issue is they want
to maintain the system of the u.s
reserve currency for oil
so take us oil off the market so that
the united states has to spend money on
other people's oil giving them an
incentive to keep producing
giving them an incentive to stay on the
us dollar right
propping up the system that's failing
yeah whereas under trump it was energy
independence
yeah i like that i like the methodology
where we just sell our own oil
and produce it you know i like the
methodology of not regime change wars
right exactly not going in nation
building and then being more
self-reliant
and it's it's fascinating to me that
it's the it's it's the conservatives
that are actually arguing for more
cooperation at this point
and it's the democrats the whole the
whole political ecosystem is like
flipped
the neocons were like we're going to go
in and we're going to remove this guy
and we're going to build this thing
right now the conservatives are like no
no we're not isolationists we just want
to do our thing and sell and
and build and that's that's
international cooperation right that's
not
isolationism so when they you know smear
the populist right as like nationalist
authoritarians or whatever it's like
they're the ones saying not to go to war
and to make america great which would
require america to negotiate and trade
with the rest of the world exactly in a
more peaceful way
but somehow these anti-war leftists view
trump as the problem
well i shouldn't say all of them because
a lot of them know how bad biden and the
democrats are but now we get joe biden
and another thing that we've heard is
you know russia's
building oil pipelines becoming oil rich
and the us is shutting shutting ours
down
taking away our independence yeah it's
crazy they don't want to drop the system
they want the us reserve currency to be
this permanent system i guess i guess
they don't want uh
people in this country working yeah
that's a that's a crazy way to go about
it because if you want russia to behave
better just take away some of their
money and you do that by bringing up the
price of american oil or putting
american oil back on the market
if americans don't produce anything but
the u.s dollar is the reserve currency
then
we don't have to produce all that much
because we can just print money and then
we get to buy whatever we want we've got
to do work that's that's unhealthy yeah
it's insane
rolling up your sleeves and doing hard
work is good for personal development
so i i look at you know many of these
socialist
young people they they claim to
represent workers but they don't work
they've never worked right
exactly i don't say every single one but
they think you know working at the
college library or starbucks is a real
job it's like
yeah go lift 50 000 pounds of luggage
working in an airport and watching these
exactly or clean a toilet or clear a
sewer yeah
what we have now are a lot of people
doing menial tasks they're unhappy with
it because there's no purpose
to it but what happens i guess
maybe there was some noble cause from
some you know
neocon or neolib where they were like if
we dominate the world
we'll never have to work again well now
we have a bunch of gluttonous
entitled individuals who don't want to
work don't know how to work and think
things should be given to them they've
they've grown up in a system that has
just given them whatever they wanted
what happens when that falls well yeah
absolutely you see like the rise of isis
like if you look at the bath party you
were talking about earlier in this
lockheed martin this constant military
they basically disbanded the iraqi
government the math party
all these people i don't know how many
thousands hundreds of thousands
became unemployed right and they have
the access to the military so they
started basically started isis yeah i
mean i don't know if there's a direct
paper trail for that
but that's basically what happened so if
they're if this global military
industrial complex is doing that to the
united states now
and they're causing mass unemployment
that we might see an uprising of some
militant
wing organization hence antifa
so there and then they could use that as
an excuse to start a war against
antifa which is what they did against
isis or that just causes massive
instability in the u.s for whatever
and like a reason to deploy troops more
money for the machine there was a
story in the wall street journal that
said how to know that inflation is here
to stay
and they said you know the fed is saying
it's temporary you know we have we have
a sudden surge of demand because the
restrictions are being lifted however
what they notice is really interesting
they said american families are flush
with cash
yeah they've been getting because of all
the stimulus right they've just been
giving people money but there's nothing
to buy so what happens
now some people couldn't pay their rent
people in big cities were having
problems
but what happens to the average family
where they're being given the stimulus
and they're just putting in their
account they're not doing anything with
it
we see this all the time in the super
chats people are like hey here's a super
chat from my stimi
it's like a lot of people weren't
sweating that much they got this money
some people said they bought doge with
it some people were saying you know that
they were buying bitcoin or whatever but
so now we're hearing that a lot of
people have a savings
they have cash that means they don't
need jobs
so mcdonald's and these other fast food
restaurants are offering 500
000 sign on bonuses no one needs the
money
or i shouldn't say no one but a lot of
people don't so they don't take the job
not only that you can't buy the things
you want i i hear every day
for my friends like man i've been trying
to buy a ps5 i can't get one
if the ps5 doesn't exist why would
someone
go get a job to buy one if you can't buy
it you can't buy it
so what do they really want right now so
that means a lot of people who normally
would be like hey i need to get a job
because i really want to get the new
playstation are going to be like i don't
need to
yeah i can live in a van and just sit
here then you have people who have tons
of money in their savings saying
as soon as the ps5 comes out i can go
buy it why get a job i've got money
in the bank the only problem is if you
don't work to make stuff
there's no stuff to buy exactly so this
seems like
either accidentally maybe it's on
purpose the mass printing of money which
binds not gonna do another six trillion
dollars yeah hyperinflation is here to
stay but it's worse than that
supply won't come back if no one needs
to work and if no one needs to work then
nothing gets made and if i think it's
made no one buys anything
this to me sounds like it is the great
reset i think the left if we let them go
unchecked
that's what they want is they want total
control because right now with cova
they're able to accelerate the program
they've been working on for years they
kill off all the industry jobs through
over regulation
the right establishment does it too at
the altar of the free market
and then the culture war coming in and
saying that everybody must go to college
and you don't really
want to have a family you don't really
need to
get married have kids and all that type
of stuff you you can't have kids right
now i mean climate change
we might all die it's irresponsible
right yeah so they they want to be able
to control people
government becomes family government
becomes god and then now we have the
stimulus coming in
kovid just let them fully accelerate i
think the economic part because then
they got the they had been talking about
ubi for a long time and people were like
we're not going to do ubi
and they kept pushing it and then boom
it's like well guys global pandemic no
one can work let's just get them all
hooked on free cash
it's total control but it's not ubi it's
iub it's our new year
it's indefinite unemployment benefits
okay yeah so it's even worse
yeah but it is interesting over the past
year
and now we're we're halfway into this
year yeah people haven't been able to
buy
all the things they wanted there's been
shortages of everything and they're
trying to
try to condition people that this is the
new norm that hey you're just going to
go long periods where like you can't
work but we got you
but you're not really going to be able
to work hard to get the things that you
want because that's not obtainable
anymore
you know i will say first and foremost i
think it's good if people
aren't being driven by material
possessions for their self-worth
i think the idea that uh if people learn
how to roll up their sleeves and go chop
some wood to get their homes instead of
digging coal and burn itself i like that
idea yeah but this is a
not a conservative problem i think
conservatives for the most part know how
to chop lumber and
take care of themselves this is a big
city liberal problem they're the ones
who are going to be left high and dried
this is
i'll tell you what i find fascinating
all this is happening whether it's just
a natural flow of the system or
it's intentional before covert there was
this big push on youtube for van life
have you seen this stuff yeah so is it a
coincidence that
youtube is promoting all these van life
videos people go on youtube and they say
hey
ditch your homes go live in a van quit
your job
yeah it's like okay so you can't own a
bunch of stuff right you won't own a
bunch of stuff you'll live in a van
you'll take up less space and humans
will spread out i'm like
i like the idea of van life i personally
love the idea of
being self-sufficient and personally
responsible yeah and encouraging these
people in cities to
do something so i have no problem with
but i do find it very
interesting that this narrative emerges
then we get the whole lockdown thing
i think when it comes to covid the
democrats immediately said don't let a
good crisis go to waste
absolutely and and so i'll clarify too
i'm not saying you know
what i'm saying specifically is covid
was exploited by
progressives and leftists for their
climate change agenda what i mean by
that is
very early on they weren't on board with
with this idea of like
you know locking down talking now yeah
fauci was saying no going to cruise no
big deal
all of a sudden they flipped like wait a
minute actually we should shut things
down we should
you know pause everything we should stop
travel they said trump was wrong for
banning travel
actually yeah i think they realized like
wait a minute this is very good
politically for what we've been trying
to do
then all of a sudden a 15 day to stop
the spread turned into you're still here
i'm still watching my state we're still
there yeah because uh and and
and uh not now vaccine passports i think
we saw in the new york times the planet
is finally healing because of the
lockdowns
they very much were like can we just
keep this thing going as
long as possible right because it serves
our agenda i think they saw that
um a lot of the things that the media
and even people on the right said that
trump was crazy for preaching
on the campaign trail when he said we
can bring back american manufacturing
you know the all the economists said no
those jobs are gone and dead and there's
no way that working-class wages can rise
like that
that had been the rule of economics for
years but trump between 2017 and right
before covet came like working-class
wages were rising
and the economy was doing really really
well and so they were about a year out
from the presidential election and so
like you said
don't let a good crisis go to waste like
let's let's accelerate this and you can
do that when you have the media pretty
much 100 percent on your side
yeah cnn particularly yeah right the
cuomo brothers
you know it's remarkable too because
people can make fun of their low ratings
all day and night but they get hundreds
of millions of views on youtube
youtube puts them on the front page
right you search for this news
cnn comes up absolutely i can do you
know a two hour interview with you
and then cnn can produce a one-minute
clip and if you search youtube what are
you gonna get you're gonna get the cnn
one-minute clip they were posting death
number cover death numbers i mean uh
project veritas right yeah really blew
the lid off of that it's just
insidious panic for views basically yeah
and then trump sent out the uss comfort
out there and they refused to use it
while
you know cuomo and de blasio are still
old people back in the
old folks homes you mentioned that
things were going really well under
trump
economically it wasn't just wages a lot
of the things the progressives
had been demanding were naturally
occurring like a four-day work week
several large businesses announced that
they were doing four-day work weeks
because they were doing so well
yeah reduced work hours a lot of
businesses announced this paid vacations
benefits
all of a sudden we started seeing
businesses be like we're going to pay
more we're going to do vacations the
economy is doing so well
yeah so it's different from an
artificial inflated wage increase right
like
the government mandates it or it's
required because of mass spending
this was legitimate it was true the
economy was kicking up
people were having vacations people were
doing well i remember when we were
starting this show i went to a furniture
place and i was like we got to buy
furniture for the show and the lady
there was like 2019 was the best year of
my life
because this was january of 2020's like
december january
we had a guy come out doing landscaping
and he was like last year was the best
year i ever had
so this was genuinely people doing
commerce with each other but that's the
opposite of what a lot of these
democrats wanted exactly
they didn't want everyone buying and
building more right they want a
retraction yep
they want people living in vans under
trump that's right people were building
castles for themselves figuratively like
they're improving their homes they were
growing their families things were
better than ever
those people are harder to control you
you want the i'm the guy that gives you
your income
i tell you what little pods you can live
in like you can't go have any of the
resources i'll give you the resources
that's where
the left has just become the
authoritarian the authoritarians i'll
tell you what's funny
we have we have the meme you know i will
not eat the bugs i will not live in the
pod yeah i think it's funny because i've
said on the show
numerous times i don't mind eating bugs
if i if i have to because i think
if you're if you're going to be gritty
hardcore survivalist and want to be
responsible you'll do what you got to do
to survive
and i don't mind living in a pod if it's
like i'm in the forest i've got my own
little hut that i've built and i'm
responsible for myself i'm fine with
that sure
the funny thing is the the city dwelling
liberal types have been living in the
pot already
yeah like new york's been famous for
their cubicle
apartments where it's like the kitchen
and the the bathroom like
there's a toilet in your kitchen you
know yeah yeah everything's crammed
together so
people in the cities have already been
living in the pods right now the new
stores are coming out saying hey go eat
the cicadas go
go eat the bugs yeah yeah that's the
city people you live in the country we
got chickens outside
right we have we have farms everywhere
out here you drive up you walk in
you got fresh meat yup you live in the
city you might got to eat the bugs yup
but
so i i'm like you know if they want to
do their thing the only issue is
they want everyone to do the same thing
they want they want rules
that are based off of a city perspective
that will affect literally everybody
so then you live in the middle of
nowhere and you've got you know a cow
and you wanna you know produce some beef
and then you get federal regulators
saying you can't we're putting a hold
so we we recently went to farms and then
we were told like
there's a shortage because that usda or
whatever regulatory agency was saying we
weren't allowed to
you know serve up the beef or something
yeah they were like restricting the
dates because of covid
then you get the gun laws they want to
make people who live in the middle of
nowhere who aren't
the problem right live by the rules of
the people in the city who are the
problem
full control everything they're doing is
is just geared towards that full control
because people
in the country that are self-sufficient
or that have their hands on a key lever
of the economy production
like they're independent they they as
they say cling to their gods and their
guns and they build families and they're
kind of hard to go screw with as opposed
to the
the guys that live in the pods in the
city that are waiting to work on the gig
economy or
they're begging for the next tech job
you know i i think it's funny too it's
like
it's interesting like conservatives are
defending liberals in a sense
because they're like we shouldn't have
to do these things and i'm like wait
guys guys guys like
if you live in the country and you
already know how to source your own food
how to start your own fires
your profession with weapons i
understand not the regulation pushing
back
but if they want to live in the city and
live in pods and eat bugs hey go for it
yeah just let them
see yeah yeah yeah don't complain
they're the ones who are gonna have to
do it the cities are the ones who are
gonna have to dramatically change
right you know is it like a
miscalculation by these city dwellers
uh out of ignorance that they're that
they're trying to legislate
city doctrine for everyone across the
country or is it
do you think it's more malicious i think
at the top levels it's more malicious
because you do
i think the the top of the left wing
they really want that full authoritarian
control
i think they've done a good job of kind
of brainwashing um
lower information people and they've
done that by infiltrating the media and
the education system
and most people that are going to live
in a city they've been told that hey to
make it in the big city
you need to have a college degree in
something you know and so i think the
universities had just became an
indoctrination
factory a long time ago where they've
been sold this whole religion of like
hey whoever's in charge is who you
listen to
is the professor in school and now it's
the government as long as we get
our our team in government that's
exactly who you listen to and if the
other team gets in the mean orange man
like no matter what he says like that's
got to be wrong and
it's not just wrong he's a nazi and so
whatever you whatever you need to do
to take that away is the right thing and
you're you're morally superior
i i think if i was gonna make a
prediction either there's gonna be a
great upheaval a very serious conflict
or
within two three years everyone's gonna
be living in pods and eating bugs
no joke i think you know uh people out
in the country will still have their
farm animals probably be less likely to
be eating bugs
but the way things are going the way the
the political uh
agenda is going i that that's where
we're headed i think this is a testing
period right now i mean i think we're on
the precipice of either
the country drastically changing and we
becoming way more
authoritarian where we have to listen to
whoever is in washington dc
and they they have very control of
intimate aspects of our lives
or i think we're going to see a huge
pushback i'm i'm optim cautiously
optimistic i should say
that in 22 there's going to be a bunch
of america first candidates go and take
the house and the senate back and then
we're going to have two years of
of hard legislative fights hard culture
war fights media fights
but i do believe then we're going to be
able to get enough momentum to take the
country back in 2024.
yeah so right now the democrats have a
very very
very slim majority control right they
don't technically have the senate but
the tie breaker goes to the democrats so
they do have that power but they can't
break the filibuster
so not only that they have to convince
manchin of everything and he's a west
virginia democrat so it's
hard for them to move they do have the
house and there have been republican
defectors like on the january 6
commission so they do have that
yeah however it seems like things are
really
bad yeah you know uh so they're they're
saying but inflation's gonna make
everyone's wages go i read this article
they were like
don't be scared of inflation it means
your wage will go up
and i'm like wow preying on the
ignorance your wage will go up
after the cost of everything else goes
up and your savings is decimated it's a
tax on everybody
and then right this is what's funny
about joe biden saying no
no you make less than four hundred
thousand dollars you know you know not a
penny in taxes right you're rolling
better calf care so he says that but
what what and then all these you know
lefty socialists say see he's not taxing
us and then he goes i'm gonna print six
trillion dollars
yeah and that is a tax on all of these
people he's
he's taking your savings by printing
this money yep
the value of your money goes down yes so
yeah your wage will go up after the fact
after they've taken your savings
through indirect means yeah and a lot of
people uh
they don't realize it so because of
these things we've uh so let me just let
me just list
some uh some problems with the democrats
right now yeah
i i i'm i self-reflect i'm looking at
all the biden stuff
and i'm like do i have biden derangement
syndrome like was i
just tribalistically like trump's not
that bad right now bidens and i just
biden's bad okay i've tried to give
biden credit on things you know
uh he sped up the vaccine rollout and i
was like you know okay if he's
increasing the timeline it's working
i'll say it's a good thing right if it's
an improvement because i try to i want
to make sure i'm not just screeching it
however he reopened the homestead
facility which is the migrant children
expanding the mcallen facility kids are
sleeping in dirt
now i'm not going to blame him for these
kids because he's right but
he is also the guy who ended trump's
remaining mexico policy which is causing
the pull factor
he's now smuggling children his
administration in the dead of night to
other states
you've got the policy in syria the
missile strikes the the movement of
soldiers
the funding of groups with israel and
palestine just exacerbating everything
a breakdown of middle eastern relations
hyperinflation
the unemployment benefits the mass
spending of money and i'm like
man this guy really is torching
everything yeah
so maybe yeah it will be enough that
come 2022
people vote for the america first
republicans because i'll say two things
um first maybe a lot of people are
disillusioned by the whole system and
are gonna walk away yeah
but maybe that will inspire a bunch of
non-traditional republicans to iran
probably like you to be like america
first let's fix this country let's do
better
because i'm not a fan of the republican
party no neither am i and i think a big
mistake that republicans could make is
think that they can stop the america
first movement because if they go and
they throw their money behind
traditional candidates the base that got
trump is a victory
they're just not going to come out and
vote it'd be a huge mistake for the
republicans to make this
make the mistake to think that people
are loyal to the republican party like
they're not they're loyal to trump they
were loyal to
america first and it wasn't just trump i
mean there were some people who were
you know they they love trump and i like
the guy a lot too and i think he's a
great president but it's not about a
cult of personality it's about the set
of values that he put forward
and i think if the republican party
doesn't fully embrace those
they're going to get taken over by
america first eventually but they could
really screw up in this this critical
period that we're at right now there are
a lot of people that
you know live and die by trump they
scream trump they love
trump they have trump flags and there
are a lot of people who voted for him
who are like
well he believes in this country it's
the best we got
exactly yeah and he's willing to fight
back against the permanent ruling class
like if you just have a career
politician go in there have we picked
anybody else that was on that stage in
2016 it would have been the continuation
of the bush obama era and the uniparty
yeah how how amazing is it that uh like
how many countries on the planet
are their own country second you know
what i mean
yeah right so so it's it's funny how the
idea of america first gets smeared and
i'm confused by that right it's also how
they smeared the idea of populism
i was always confused by that i remember
when it first came out and they were
like these populists are bad and it's
dangerous
and i was like what are they what are
they trying to say i'm confused what do
they mean by that
right and then i'm like wait are they
literally saying the will of the people
is bad
like when the people are having a
democrat a democratic election in their
constitutional republic that's not a
good thing and the elites should be in
charge by virtue of them being elites
yes that's literally what they were
saying it was very it was very it was
confusing to me
and then i was like oh oh wait wait they
literally mean popular
they mean like the regular people are
like hey this is how we want things to
be run
i think there's certainly some arguments
in that you know we criticize the
democrats because they're trying to get
everyone possibly to vote right so they
want 16 year olds voting who have no
political experience
so certainly in that respect okay i can
understand the argument but i'm still
not going to vote for a wall street
banker by virtue of him being rich
exactly that's the most ridiculous idea
ever so you get trump
but now you're now you start you're
starting to see more and more
politicians who are like
we're going to do right by america then
we can focus on everything else
what's amazing to me is you get on a
plane you're going to play what do they
say
secure your own face mask before
securing the face match yeah that's
right yeah
next to you and we're in a country that
during a pandemic
when our businesses were locked down the
omnibus spending bill was sending
tax dollars to other countries yeah that
is insane
billions that true i wasn't it was more
than billion trillions yeah i mean
we had 12 million to like pakistani
gender studies yeah
how does that i would rather give 12
random americans 12 million dollars than
send it overseas because at least it'll
stay in the economy 100 yeah but it's
because of the petro dollar because they
want these other countries using the
dollar to maintain
that that system and those dollars make
their way back into politicians pockets
through lobbyists and special interests
and super pacs and like
it's a whole fixed system and you know
and it's not serving the american people
i'm i'm you know i talk about living in
the pod and eating the bugs and all that
stuff
i've got no problem i've said this all
the time if i get banned you know i'm
gonna do i'm gonna get my van drive down
to the river and go fishing just mind my
own business
i am very happy to just be sitting there
every day looking up the stars in a
little tent get a dog or whatever
i don't need much to be happy and i
think about america first
and the idea to me well sounds like a
lot of hard work
a lot of people are going to be doing a
lot of hard work to support themselves i
think it sounds really good for the
environment
because what this is the current system
you know how insane the current system
is
skateboards i mentioned this several
times you want to get a skateboard in
the united states here's what they do
they chop a tree down in canada
send it to china turn into a skateboard
right sent to california
with a tariff that's yeah with all these
tariffs why
do that that's terrible for the entire
time why not just have a guy in you know
in in pacific northwest
cut down a tree get into a skateboard
and then put on a truck and send it to
you yeah exactly
waste so when i when i hear about this
idea of like bring the factories back
get americans back to work
we'll be working we probably won't be
the biggest name
you know the wealthiest in the planet
you're not going to have 12 new iphones
every year
but you're going to have what you need
you're going to be responsible for what
you produce you're going to be happy
with it
yep instead we know we have the opposite
we have entitlement people who just get
yeah they they want stimulus checks they
want they live in big cities they work
at buzzfeed
where they get paid tons of money to
write articles about nonsense yep i'm
not a fan i really see this fourth
turning in effect um
are you familiar with the fourth time
and how like every generation people
become distance from the past
you know that people don't they're so
soft
that they don't that they have this this
this i don't know air of like
assumption or this like belief like
they're owed
things and and peace and prosperity and
yeah that doesn't
that doesn't like accidentally happen
that's right they're they're they're
they've they're it's been ingrained
look when i when i i have a story about
my buddy started a company
he was trying to hire people he kept
hiring college grads i'll give you the
short version
and they kept screwing up and he was
like i went through you know hired two
people they screwed up i hired two more
people they screwed up i hired two more
people i'm like i can't afford to keep
doing this these people can't do the job
so then finally he hired some colle some
high school uh high school dropouts yeah
he got like the geds or something
but they had moved from i think like
utah to california or iowa
to become actors and he said these guys
were perfect
and then he realized they took the
initiative
to leave where they live to go seek you
know their riches and their adventure
and they were self-starters
when he went to people who were who had
college degrees what he found was these
are people who just did what they were
told
so they couldn't solve any problems when
a problem was presented
and then he realized like not only do i
save money but these people are
more capable i see these people going to
college
not because they're pursuing a passion
but because they were told they were
told to yep
so now for me it's like it's i typically
look for
i don't care if you have a degree or not
i care if you have a portfolio
you're passionate and you can prove it
yeah exactly i think the uh
the what happened with the greatest
generation was they went through so much
hardship and so much adversity in the
war they fought it collectively together
they all fought
so much that they didn't need to come
home and talk about it and dwell on it
but they also had stuff to do
we had this whole production industry
while the war was going on because we
had to have it and then americans just
fell in on that production industry
went to work and built the country that
we had and i think that
the byproduct of that was the boomers
and the boomers had this horrible
experience with foreign intervention in
vietnam
and so if you didn't want to go to
vietnam what'd you do you went to
college and so this whole industry
got produced around hey like all the
smart kids go to college the dumb kids
joined the military kind of spitting in
the face a little bit of rebellion too
at the boomers who uh not not the
boobers the greatest generation who took
service very very seriously
um and so now the byproduct of that is
we have
there's no collective identity of
americans we didn't collectively all go
through something
you know and then you throw in the whole
college aspect too where
the divide is now class the people that
were smart enough to go to college
to really learn how to follow
instructions properly and get
indoctrinated because the leftist
infiltrated the colleges a long time ago
and then the rest of the country who
they're those production jobs they all
got killed so they're disenfranchised
then you have the opioid epidemic and
you have all these
guys these young men just looking for
for purpose
i think a lot of these city dwelling
college educated individuals don't
realize that
what they do only exists because of the
rural
labor market the farmers particularly
right people who work in agriculture
it's really incredible how that is the
backbone of this country
i mean there's no food without these
people so you can you want to work in a
lab you want to work in a university get
your grant
well your grant only works because you
can go and buy food because someone made
that food
yeah they don't get it so what happens
is we have this system
people go to college they say going to
college is your ticket to a better
a better future they tell their kids
they'll get a better job just get a
degree
yeah just get a degree whatever it is
anything and now these kids have you
know art liberal arts degrees
follow your passion philosophy you know
i
believe it or not people do get degrees
in folklore and mythology sure yeah but
what are you going to do to sustain the
system
other you know nothing yeah these
degrees don't do anything
so you end up with a lot of people who
have a lot of useless degrees many who
have changed
their majors but still demand higher
salaries
because they've they think they're
entitled they did what they were yeah
exactly
i did what i was told i deserve it give
it to me now here's the best part
these these kids who are all graduating
and the adults the millennial adults
nearing their 40s who have this massive
debt are
now the highest income earners in the
country demanding the working class
pay their debts off yeah that's right is
this like how often does that happen in
history where the ultra rich
demand the poor i shouldn't say ultra
rich but where the wealthier
demands the government tax the poor to
pay off their debts
no there's it's a recipe for disaster is
there going to be a revolt
are are the working-class people going
to step up and be like i am not paying
your debts
you me your salary these some of these
people they get jobs at
50 grand a year to write articles for
buzzfeed right there are people at
buzzfeed who make six figures
they do really really well i mean it's a
legit company they make a lot of stuff
but how is it
that you can write you know three or
four articles per day about whatever
nonsense
you here's a here's a picture of a bunch
of cats and you'll get paid more money
than a guy who's fixing your sewer
yeah that to me is incredible and that's
a problem with our economy
i've always felt this way since i was a
kid you know i always thought like why
is it that baseball players get paid
more than
doctors yeah you know shouldn't doctors
get paid a lot more right
well whatever opinion on that i'm sure a
lot of people say well the marketplace
well here we go right now you have
people who are dredging through sewers
pulling out rat kings you know the rat
king is
when all the rats get stuck together and
they clog pipes and you pull them out
their tails are all tied in knots
yeah there are people have to put on i
knew a guy growing up his uh his
step-dad
would put on a full body suit and go
into five feet of sewage
and be trying to stick their hand in and
clear out pipes and those needles and
stuff and
and that that person gets paid less yeah
than some 24 year old degree sitting in
an office in new york
writing articles about like here's five
pictures of hamsters that'll make you
laugh
yeah that system to me makes no sense
and will be unsustainable once the
working class
the labor actually realizes that
they're getting paid less being rewarded
less for their hard work and sacrifice
yeah and not only that service members i
think that's what terrifies the
authoritarian left so much about america
first because we've
become the party of the working class
and the party the middle class we're the
ones that say hey we want people to have
a job we want them to have their
their dignity and their individual
sovereignty i think that that terrifies
the left because they're seeing that
awakening that's what was that's what
actually was so dangerous about donald
trump
because trump was like i can make your
guys's wages rise i can put our country
first you don't need to play with this
you don't need to play by this system
that has done absolutely nothing but
failure and that's why i think you've
seen the left shift their
their focus so much to all these racial
issues and the critical race theory
because any time they want to
saddle us with more debt or do
job-killing economic policies
they have to they have to distract from
that and they have to keep the races
fighting
how do you how do you convince somebody
who works at buzzfeed
for high-five figures that they're
actually worse off
than the construction worker making 25
an hour
how do you how do you convince them oh
race you make it about race and
intersectionality yep
and so there you go they've redefined
the conflict so that they can keep
people voting for them
convinced they're the saviors when in
reality
these new york you know liberal types
were in their 20s
man i'll tell you when i first walked
into that vice building
i started working at vice and the job i
had before that
i was working in non-profits and i was
getting a like base like base salary
before that
i used to work at o'hare airport and i
was loading bags yeah 10 bucks an hour
eventually made 11 bucks an hour lifting
about 50 000 pounds per day to load
these planes
and it was hard work and people got hurt
and yeah
in order to pay for their their their
families to fund their family some
people work double shifts all day every
day
and then i walk in device and i see
these people just like sitting back they
got like booze on their
on their on their table they got whiskey
they're drinking and i'm like what are
you guys doing like
chilling and i'm like you're getting
paid like fifty thousand dollars a year
not all of them advice that was
notoriously paid not that well but a lot
of these people were getting like 35 to
50 and they were doing
nothing yeah relatively nothing they did
something
you know they'd get emails from people
saying here's a story and they'd be like
cool and they take it
and then they put it on the site and
like some people won't even show up for
work
and i'm like so it's true man you move
to new york city
you can get a do-nothing job that pays
really really well how long until the
people are actually doing the labor that
supports this country
how long until they say hey wait a
minute why am i making stuff for you
and you don't do anything there is an
issue i suppose because people say hey
the market pays or the market's going to
pay
but then you look at how the policies of
of the left are are functioning today
joe biden's just taxing the working
class that's right through inflation
which and then giving money to people in
cities who aren't working yeah at a
certain point people are gonna say nah
yeah once they get start getting hungry
for sure i think when the technology is
like broad enough that you can
communicate you can establish like
pockets of resistance for the workers to
defy
like the white collar oligarchy but
we need to figure out a system that
solves for that because
throughout time the workers have been
rising up and overthrowing the
government and creating a revolution
that then they become
the new oligarchy and then produce
another
form of tyranny that another group of
workers have to rise up and overthrow
so like building a decentralized system
where
there's no oligarchy i think that's the
that's got to be the only way yeah i
think getting rid of our political
classes
is the key because we we can we can vote
we have elections we should be able to
do this but we've just
fallen in this two-party system and the
two parties have just pretty much done
the same thing which just screw over the
working class
so that's why i mean i think you saw the
establishment on both sides left and
right go after a guy so heavily like
donald trump
you know because if imagine if there was
more donald trump's like that we could
disrupt the entire system and really put
it back on a footing where
the working-class people actually had a
chance check out this story from 2018.
so this is from geekwire
clash at amazon hq construction workers
shout down
council member over plan to tax big
business
so i don't know if you saw this story
but the videos went viral and it was
absolutely hilarious
you had academic leftists wearing their
you know red salute fists
shirts and shakers shirts yeah and they
were like we want to tax this and we
want to regulate this
and a bunch of guys in yellow vests and
hard hats
were shouting them down protesting so
these
academic lefty types keep saying over
and over again we represent labor and
the working class
they don't they're the academic
intelligentsia these
they represent college kids who've never
had a job
and these middle middle-aged dudes who
work construction who are actual labor
showed up and protested them oh this
isn't we need to it was in seattle we
need to see more of this
so uh let me read a little bit they say
that so this is 2018
we have this video the clash at uh i
think it's outside of amazon
headquarters they say council member
keshama sawant asked reporters to join
her in front of amazon's iconic spheres
as she implored her colleagues not to
back down on the so-called head tax
despite amazon's announcement that it
will pause some of its growth plans
pending the council's decision
but swat struggled to get her message
across as dozens of seattle iron workers
drowned her out with chance of no head
tax yeah
i don't see these lefty you know black
lives matter types anti-for types
they're they're not labor they're not
unions they're not workers
right the unions are i i my
understanding is that many of them split
for trump
there's a big shift yeah definitely the
the worker bees of the unions that's
that's very red i think very working
well the people who run the
people who runs yeah well they're in bed
with you know the depart the chamber of
commerce and the department of labor
so yeah i mean i think that's just
another reason why they have to have
these narratives come in
um of you know racial inequality because
if all the workers like kind of woke up
and realized they were being screwed by
the same permanent class
they'd they would have a huge problem so
so right now
in this country and it's been this way
for years you have
upper class academic intelligentsia
white-collar workers claiming to
represent labor right
they don't but it is it is fascinating
because if you look back at history when
when when a lot of the philosophy and a
lot of the the ideologies were being
written and conceived of
like marx for instance there there
wasn't
like the new classes have emerged the
middle class you know it
emerged at some point upper middle class
upper lower class lower middle class
upper lower whatever
so you started to see all of a sudden
regular people now becoming landlords
they weren't typically lords but now
there's like an expansion of different
classes and what happens is you and
you end up with people who are fairly
well off relative to everybody else
but they're not super wealthy so they
view themselves
as labor well i work for this big
company i work for this billionaire
therefore i'm not upper class i am labor
but they make twice as much or three
times as much as the guys who actually
build buildings and
farm the crops right and now they're
protesting as though they
are the the suffering you know working
class but they're actually like
they're they're mid-level bourgeoisie
yep and most of them to get that job
they had to
go to college and that's where the
indoctrination started so i think we
could chip away at a lot of this too by
waiving a lot of the college degree
requirements especially like in
government if i get into office i want
to
start hiring people that don't have
college degrees i want to waive the
requirement that
to work on my staff you have to have
university yeah that's that's actually
that's been a big trend over the past
10 years actually it's been it's been
you know growing and growing
as i just stated moments ago and you
know a little in a previous
bit i don't i don't care for college
degrees you know
if you have one if you don't it's
meaningless to me yeah you show me your
portfolio show me your passion show me
you can do the job and you want to do it
then i'm down and we can work together
we can make some
cool stuff happen but when i get people
like here's my resume i went to college
for this i'm like that means
nothing to me right yeah like i do i
used to hang out at colleges you know
what i saw
i saw people going to school for like
music production just drunk all day just
and right right i'm like and then i i i
know some 16 year old kid
who was every day producing and making
music and working with bands and i'm
like and he knows a hundred times more
than that kid went to college yeah so
your degree i'm sorry your piece of
paper is great and all but
means nothing to me in fact i'll tell
you this college degrees in my opinion
detriment you know why people with
college debt require higher salaries
that's right
and if the company can't afford it
you're going to lose out to the
competition who can do the job and
doesn't have the degree
but it's the perfect means of control
like you have the ideological test there
within college and people get really
good following instructions then they're
saddled up all this debt
so they can't they have to go live in
the pod and eat the bugs because they
can't afford a house out in the country
they have to go
live in this city they can't afford to
have kids make families
you know it's genius way to control i i
i really
am not a fan of uh you know people
saying like i have no choice i have to
do it
i think about the people who got on
boats and just you know just landed on
the shores of nothing yeah
let's start building yeah imagine that
like first ship that came from europe to
the united states
lucky enough to meet in some
circumstances like you know the story of
the first thanksgiving yeah okay we're
starving it's winter and the native
americans like we're gonna help you out
yeah and then there's a lot of bad
history there for sure right
but but outside of that there were
people who said i'm gonna get a boat for
three months
you know one in five people will die on
this journey right literally just in the
ocean before we even get anywhere and
then once we get there nothing there
we're gonna do it now you have people
who are like
i should be able to have a house the
houses exist give it to me yeah exactly
so so even people who you know they get
degrees and like i have no choice i have
to go move to the city it's like
have you considered just living the way
humans have lived like why why do you
feel entitled to
all of the luxuries of life right i i i
i think about this you know uh when i
saw the i was on the williamsburg bridge
in new york
free to use for everybody somebody paid
for it
somebody built it but you just get it
for free that's the kind of thing that
people don't understand
they don't realize how much work and
suffering and sacrifice
was done for them so that they can have
all of these free things yeah
now they're entitled to now they demand
it yep my attitude's always been like
dude if i
if i was in the middle of the woods and
i was buck naked that's that's zero
that's like that's where i'm like okay i
got nothing i better get to work
yeah if i was you know if i had a pointy
stick hey i'm up
one like i got stuff this is good 26 is
great yeah no but
we're way beyond that we live in luxury
we've got clean drinking water we've got
hot water even even even our homeless in
this country are overweight
yeah yeah it's actually a problem we
should get them better food they're
eating bad food
but you know we're we're almost a victim
of our own success
we definitely are now people are trapped
in this entitlement mentality instead of
realizing what life is and
that you're entitled to nothing so how
do we get out of that you know how do we
get people back to the
chopping the tree down you know just to
get the wood for the winter to
heat their homes to be responsible for
themselves and not demand all this stuff
from cities from governments yeah i
think we have a lot of work to do
with messaging like the more work that
you do and the more independent you are
the more that you actually have your
freedom like you
we need to shift the culture from like
hey you you have all these things that
are entitled to you
like you by the time you're 30 years old
you should have a house you're like well
no not really like you should work hard
enough to get a house you should have
the
the means to pursue life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness that's what well
that's what's so great about this
country but
that doesn't mean anything's guaranteed
now this is where i'm i'm well i think
many on the left and the right will
probably agree well i should say many in
the left were paying attention
it used to be a lot easier to buy a
house it did the house is the housing
market wasn't as crazy but you know the
issue is
federal reserve the system we have where
joe biden is able to just snap his
fingers and
flood the market with money yep strips
everyone's a bill it hyperinflates
yeah it strangles the market and so it
is getting harder and harder to buy that
house
yeah my attitude is you know man i'm not
going to be demanding of anyone else
i'm responsible for myself and if i have
to go live in a cardboard box because
that's what i have in them access to
like well you know what no one's got to
build anything for me right so i'll go
into the middle of the woods and i'll
hike into the mountains and i'll figure
something out i'll live in a bus in
alaska if i have to you know beaten down
but it is an issue if our society can't
function because people can't buy houses
because the market's been just
absolutely manipulated and broken yep
and then i'm not surprised we're headed
towards
you know some kind of crisis yeah we
just had so much individual agency taken
away from us
by the federal government you know for
varying reasons but the but the end
state has been total control like the
fed's a great example
so i think we just need to get that
rugged sense of what it means to be an
independent american
back i think there's cultural work to do
there but i think really expressing to
the american people
the economic crisis that we're about to
be in because all these different
countries right now could chip away at
our economy china can pull out the rug
from right underneath us so
we i think if we got back on a wartime
footing to getting our production back
online
i i think we could potentially see a
shift it might take as much of it as a
as a generation for people to understand
like hey you're not entitled to anything
but you can go work hard
well let's let's think about this joe
biden's got a six trillion dollar
spending package and a lot of it
includes repairing bridges and you know
roads and infrastructure like what what
are your thoughts on that
well the if if it was just truly
infrastructure i'd be okay with that but
his infrastructure bill is like 6
trillion
and he considers everything it's like
child care is infrastructure and like
all these different programs or
infrastructure
like he just if he says infrastructure
then he gets to spend money on it and
it just doesn't work that way so there's
infrastructure work to be done for sure
but like what
when you go and you repair a road or a
bridge like that takes concrete that
takes steel so let's produce that here
in america like why
why don't we have steel and concrete
factories getting back online if we need
to repair the
infrastructure it almost sounds like
it's on purpose
you know so here's a few of the problems
they say they want to increase the
corporate tax
the corporation's got to pay their fair
share yep then they say also
we've got to pay everybody a higher wage
also
free trade no tariffs on imported goods
exactly
then china says they complete the puzzle
they say no taxation here
cheap labor with no human rights and
when you put those things together what
do you get
a corporation says okay so it's going to
cost us an extra 10 million for salaries
it's going to cost us an extra 10
million in corporate tax
and we'll save 20 million by putting our
factory in china
yeah but a factory in china right we can
ship the goods in for free it's
incentivizing it
now you look at joe biden's
infrastructure plan and yes like you
know childcare's infrastructure was the
meme
at the same time as he's trying to
rebuild infrastructure which
some of it is a good thing he's also
still in uh pushing the unemployment
and now the child tax credit which is
going to give up to like three thousand
dollars per family yeah which just gives
people money so they don't need to work
which means if you give a bunch of
people money they don't work you're not
going to hi
find people in the united states who are
going to want to produce the steel or
the concrete right in the quarries
they're going to be back i'm good and
then the only option is for those
companies that are getting contracted by
the federal government biden steps in
and says
i got a billion dollars to build this
bridge so we're going to need you know x
amount of steel x amount of concrete
the company's going to say wish we could
find somebody to do it but nobody wants
to work
i guess we'll buy from china yep and
it's once again incentivizing sending
our infrastructure
our capabilities to china yep and then
who do they have
do the labor i mean joe biden just
opened up our southern border
so we have we have then here comes the
illegal immigrants for the handful of
working-class americans that do want to
work
why are you going to hire working-class
americans you got to pay their health
care you got to pay a minimum wage
i'd you know you can just go hire a
couple of illegal immigrants and
save a whole bunch of money and then
whenever you're done with them you can
pretty much discard them so
they're being gutted yeah we're
absolutely being gutted yeah another um
i guess you would call it a danger with
our
regarding our sovereignty is the the way
that we
get paid the way that our money system
works like right now you work 40 hours
for a company
and then you trust that they're going to
give you the money for it
yeah you make youtube videos and then
you're going to trust that when youtube
says we're going to pay you that ad
revenue
that it's going to arrive but you still
have to trust that the company's going
to send you the money
you trust that paypal is going to take
that money and send it to you sometimes
they don't
i know and so we're on the precipice of
smart a smart contract economy where the
money just
automatically goes there's no middleman
that holds it and sends it yeah
that's a that's a big that's a big
danger how cool would it be
you know with with the crypto markets
you didn't get paid
a week after you work or 30 days like if
your contractor
you're literally just watching the
crypto trickle into your account
every minute you work your your your
your taxes were paid instantly i mean
that would be so
and they could be that's another thing
too like you know we got a bungled up
tax system
we do the the irs knows what we owe
they could literally just deduct it like
have a nice day they play a guessing
game you know well you know uh
what they say is that these big tax
preparation companies are have
incentivized not to end the system so
yeah they lobby to keep the machine
going and it just wastes everybody
everybody's time and energy for the sake
of the economy to keep the machine going
hey if they want to do a great reset can
we start with resetting the tactics
yeah seriously because a lot of these
taxes don't make sense oh what a what a
what a breath of relief that would be
for people to have that stuff taken care
of
i think crypto is is going to be awesome
but so uh you have you followed bitcoin
and all that stuff
i have a little bit yeah so i think you
know bitcoin is the one true key
these other cryptos are i'm not one of
these doom sayers a lot of people
hate what they're called altcoins like
ethereum these other companies
no i'm a big fan i think the technology
is fantastic max kaiser got on your
brand
what kaiser got kaiser campaign i didn't
agree with your max kind of
he loved he came over he's like bitcoin
all the way but i'm but yeah i disagree
with them you do
yeah max is saying all the alternative
coins are bad i
don't agree with that i i don't think so
i think bitcoin's fantastic it's
decentralized
and i think if we were operating on that
system or some kind of standard with
that
you can't get a fed to come in and pump
money and devalue the system you get
bitcoin your bitcoin's good
because it's a decentralized system no
one controls would you would you say
that bitcoin is
backed by the us dollar or like bitcoin
completely
replacing the dollar uh i i don't think
it replaces the dollar yeah i think it
holds value and they call it digital
gold right so it's not necessarily
something you're going to be using every
day for spent for for
buying stuff however uh max said once
it's around half a million to
between like half a million per bitcoin
like a million dollars per bitcoin
then you'll probably that's what it
stabilizes when it's like you know above
gold or whatever
uh bitcoin is a store of value it's
almost like it's a bank account
yeah so a lot of these companies track
your bitcoin in dollar value
yeah and it goes up all the time now the
recent crash
people who are inexperienced with
bitcoin are freaking out but people who
have been using bitcoin for a long time
don't know don't care yeah because
if you're holding bitcoin you're going
you're you're not losing value if you're
holding dollars you're losing value oh
yeah
so that's why i think bitcoin is truly
going to be incredible
there's some issues with it it's fully
trackable it's extremely transparent oh
yeah kind of a bad way
but i look at this as maybe that is a
way to fix
a lot of these problems they're not
going to be able to pump money into the
market if people lose confidence a
dollar and they switch to a
cryptocurrency market
you've got smart contracts people get
can get paid on time there's more trust
in the system
however the only way that can happen is
if confidence in the dollar is lost
which would be
some kind of massive inflation
yeah yeah and then people switch over it
would be funny if it becomes dogecoin
yeah it just becomes like some some big
standard yeah i i don't know though i'm
i'm confident
and if i were to make a bet not giving
anybody advice
i wouldn't be surprised if in 10 15
years we were on a bitcoin standard of
some sort
if you look at the trends like the
banking trends that that makes a lot of
sense
yeah ceos of jp morgan other yeah
fully on on board i think as long as we
controlled that and then we actually
were a production-based independent
country
that wouldn't be a huge deal i think if
china goes and says like hey the us
dollar is so worthless
you guys need to buy into whatever china
coin or some form of
chinese bitcoin like that could be a
major problem for the entire world and
i'm sure that's what china
i mean absolutely again with the way
that we're running up our debt like they
could do something like that fairly
easily
that's what's scary yeah if uh if we
don't do this right
and i and and i think we're not no china
china could absolutely create a
centralized coin and that could replace
the reserve currency and say we only do
business in china coin
that's the smartest way to fight us
really i mean thucydides trap of like us
going and duking it out and shooting
with china like i i don't think that's
necessarily gonna happen but if i were
china i would just continue to
purchase our debt so we gain the
confidence that that's always gonna be
there we keep printing money
they keep watching us eat ourselves
alive with critical race theory and
racial intentions
and then at the time of your choosing
you choose to pull out and stop buying
our debt
yep i thought about this a long time ago
you know
like years ago maybe like a decade ago i
started my friend and i was like man
what if china just one day said yo we're
not going to make your stuff anymore
yeah we would just instantly be like cut
off from everything we'd be sitting here
hold an empty bag and i was like man
what if they said that and then declared
war
right we're totally screwed yeah so
i guess we can just fire the missiles
but right then
what yeah exactly maybe maybe that's
intentional because you know they say
that uh
it prevents war right they want these
free trade agreements so that we can't
go to war because the u.s is too
dependent upon china
no it sounds to me like when you look at
what's going on with international trade
china's been exempt from everything
they talk about climate change and
reducing carbon emissions how often do
they mention china right and china says
we're not going to do that that's for
the rest of you guys to
beat each other up with they build new
new coal power plants right
so so let's let's let's let's focus on
that i suppose here's my question right
america first not isolationist obviously
right you mentioned that you know with
isis it was like this this real evil
that needed to be stopped yeah
so it's hard to know um when america
first becomes
we need to do something internationally
yeah so i so a good friend of mine
cassandra fairbanks has
been on the show before and i said you
know we look at china we look at the the
uyghur camps and everything it's very
difficult what do we do
we don't want war or we don't want to
just go and fight this massive world war
with china
and it would be catastrophic but do we
just watch as they commit atrocities
cassandra said you know she's like no
i'm anti-war 100 there's no like
tons of countries are committing
atrocities we don't get involved we we
can't just go and start war with a
massive country
and i was like what about trade
sanctions and she said well that leads
to war
so so how do we deal with something like
that right if we if we want to take care
of america first we want to be
self-reliant
at what point would we intervene say
with concentration camps
yeah i think with foreign interventions
we have to have a really clear
national security objective like this
whatever it is overseas threatens
america threatens our sovereignty
threatens our ability to conduct free
and fair commerce
but there also has to be a clear end
state like we go out and we isis is a
great example we go we take out the
territorial caliphate and like then it's
mission complete
we come home we call it good we still
leave the ability to collect
intelligence occasionally strike if
needed
but we don't go over there and occupy
like there's a clear-cut objective like
with the uyghur camps and a lot of these
human rights
violations that go on throughout the
entire world
it's just a slippery slope and like so
we intervene then in china
hypothetically
where else do we intervene so my my uh
whenever the far left says like hey
anywhere there's an atrocity it's our
responsibility that responsibility to
protect doctrine that like samantha
power
and a lot of the folks in the obama
administration just love
um to that i say hey well then go sell
that to the american people and then
tell them that we need to start the
draft because we're going to be at war
freaking
everywhere because if you never traveled
outside this country i hate to break it
to you like the world's a dark and
dangerous place
how about a bill that uh whenever there
is a conflict
whenever we see an atrocity we put it up
for a national vote
yeah everybody votes and if you vote yes
you're drafted i i would be down with
that
someone yeah that was actually proposed
i think before world war ii
they're like anybody who wants to vote
for war you got to go join up
because you can't make someone else
fight for you yeah i'm down
because i'll tell you this if there was
something where i truly thought we had
to intervene
then i'd be the first to be like what do
i need to do right exactly like if i'm
looking at the concentration camps
in china i'll be like how can i help
obviously i don't think
frontline infantry makes sense for me
but i'll absolutely do what i can
yeah what makes sense however i'm not
absolutely convinced we should intervene
right i think assange made a really good
point
she mentioned you know there's a bunch
of countries like you know you know you
see these groups and
in africa and nigeria what they're doing
to these young girls and
do we intervene there like don't we do
i mean that's where i'm like hey start
the draft because it's everywhere guys
exactly but i think with with uh an
actor like china or pretty much any of
these countries
um that aren't in total anarchy already
us being
the economically strongest country in
the entire world that gives us
a position of advantage so then we can
say hey china turns out number one we
don't need you
number two if you want to do business
with us then how about you stop the
genocide in those weaker camps yeah and
until you do that we're just not going
to do business with you we could be
doing that but disney is saying thank
you
right exactly yeah disney and the nba
and whatever
whatever yeah the pro wrestler guy like
what was that all about like insane
that was that's pathetic yeah that just
shows their control it's so apparently
it i don't know if it was uh some some i
think might have been the movie i'm not
sure there's like an 85
revenue decrease i don't have the story
yeah in china was that fast nine
yeah so f9 i guess they're in their
revenue from chinese theaters dropped by
86
because of what he said wow you know you
know what i would do
if like if it were me i was like in a
movie and and then i said i've been a
lot of countries i'm in taiwan and
they're like
i'd be like dude if you guys are mad
whatever i don't say you have a nice day
yeah yeah exactly man like it's like am
i going to pick and choose who's
offended who's not offended no if you're
offended well you know
sorry i guess yeah and that just shows
how much how much
how china has their fingers in every
aspect of well it's
scary it's an issue of uh
the violent tendencies of leftists or
the threat so when you look at
uh antifa versus say you know
the anti-woke classically liberal
individuals
big tech and these corporations always
side with antifa because they're the
real threat
right you know look they're not
concerned about a bunch of
intellectual dark web types you know
could you imagine like dave rubin
leading a pitchfork march to like
twitter hq and like throwing bricks
through the window right it's
not gonna happen he's gonna he's gonna
sit in his studio and he's gonna ask
quit people questions
uh but antifa will show up with bricks
so when an argument breaks out who's
twitter gonna side with
oh yeah well dave rubin's not going to
throw a brick at us right so antiva will
yeah so when it comes to china you know
you can you can smack talk in the united
states people are still going to go see
the movie
yeah not in china though do you
apologize to so
you apologize to china but let me ask
you this right so um
before we get into the super chats we'll
do one more uh you're in the um
the southern uh southern part of
washington the district you're seeing to
represent third
and that's that's that's the board
that's the front line that is from
washington
to to oregon right that vancouver
washington and the river and then
portland that's right you're the first
line of defense against the the portland
uh antifa and they're we are they're
they're violent mobs but uh no in all
seriousness
yeah what do you what tell me your
thoughts on what's going on with that
violence because it does cross over into
vancouver
over there so uh i mean this is your
this is where you're seeking represent
how would you deal with this what are
your thoughts yeah it has to be dealt
with so we need to treat
antifa and blm like terrorist
organizations like we need to use the
tools of the federal government the fbi
the us marshals go after them like
organized criminals and
and terrorists so we start arresting
these guys and charging them with
federal terrorism charges
that's going to take away a lot of the
incentive to go out and riot but not
not the groups you mean the leaders the
leaders the leaders yeah
but so so let's let's let's get into the
nitty-gritty though i mean a lot of
people
do have a right to fly that flag and
speak their minds oh yeah we're not
talking about going after them
no i'm not no i mean at this point like
right now after a year
a year plus of this amount of violence
we know who the leaders of antifa are i
mean i know portland police officers and
they're like yeah i know who all the
agitators are at this point like i've
arrested them and
we have to let them go right you know
over and over again these are people who
actively organize violence right who and
terror
and terror yeah there are a lot of
people who might fly the anti-flag of
the blm flag who don't
yeah exactly however there's there's a
very serious challenge where you get to
a point where
you know in portland for instance
they're linking arms
performing uh forming a human shield as
people throw explosives from behind them
right
at a certain point whether you're active
in that organization you're aiding into
betting you're indian better
yeah you might not get the 10-year
federal terrorism charge but you're
going to get anything embedding and
once we start actually having
repercussions for these people the
the base of support is going to die down
a good deal i think
you know when it comes to the leaders we
absolutely need the feds to go in but
they're too occupy preoccupied with you
know january 6 or whatever
i think for the the people who are just
you know doting about and
and bumbling and providing that warm
body as a shield
you put them in in you lock up for a
weekend and actually just
charge them for you know look a lot of
these people are going to get six months
if they actually got convicted that's
not the end of the world for any person
that's not a felony charge
that would put an end to a lot of it oh
absolutely but what happens is these
people they shall play
they're playing a game they are there
yeah so you get people who actually are
engaging in terrorist activities
i'll put it this way you know uh michael
flynn
he he made the statement we mentioned
early on in the show and we never
actually started a segment on it but
he said uh someone asked him about a
mayanmar-style coup and he said it
should happen here and a lot of people
were like oh but he's not being serious
he has no power
he's larping and i'm like that that's
irrelevant what you think he's doing
there are people who are cheering for
that that's dangerous like saying there
should be a military coup in here
people are going to hear that and that's
one more grain of sand so on its own
that may be fairly significant but not
the most powerful thing ever done by any
person or might not lead to a
catastrophic moment
but when you get some regular
dumb lefty type who has no idea what's
going on put on a black mask
and show they have become a grain of
sand which has made that a heap
antifa would not be able to be burning
down these buildings weren't not for
these people right so
if you know these people are doing it or
you don't i put it this way
imagine people are like hey everybody
show up at you know the the bank of
america on 7th street
we're gonna we're gonna protest and you
show up and a bunch of people put on ski
masks and go and start demanding money
and you stand there linking arms
i mean you're helping them yeah yeah
yeah exactly you get in trouble
exactly so uh anyway um so
the leaders who are organizing the
violence yeah we know they're doing it
they're not getting charged but what
about groups like patriot prayer because
they're they've started fights you know
some of these guys they've gone down
what are your thoughts on that so i
think by and large there's been
some of the patriot prayer guys went
down there and they were expressing
their first amendment rights i mean if
anybody went and they assaulted somebody
then i think they should be prosecuted
too
we can't have two systems it can't be
like we prosecute the guys in the maga
hat
but then we don't prosecute the guys
burning down buildings because then you
get the situation that we have
right now where you have cities on fire
for months on end because there's no
repercussions whatsoever so i think if
you act if
if you do something illegal regardless
of who you are or what your political
affiliation is like you should be
charged for it so
one of the problems we're seeing right
now is a lot of these district attorneys
are leftists yeah so when antifa walks
in there
you know they get if they get two files
one says maga once is auntie but they
say maga guy prison for life
antifa guy free to go let him go yeah
yep so it's then we can look at what
happened in new york
you had antifa show up to this proud
boys event
they're harassing people they're
attacking people one guy got robbed his
backpack was stolen
and so the proud boys are leaving and
you know there's antifa
all over the place they decide they're
gonna go at him
so the proud boys run at antifa one end
of a guy throws a bottle they get into a
fight
proud boys win kind of not surprising
but what happens then is
when when it comes to questioning by the
police antifa runs away
they refuse to cooperate the proud boys
doing the right thing
cooperate with police they got four
years in prison oh yeah and antifa
got away and no one knows who they were
right so
this is the kind of pro this is one of
the one of the problems we have in this
country it works the same way with gun
laws
you say we're going to ban this gun okay
well the criminals don't care yeah
there's a video going around right now
that they're saying it's like oh a group
of people with assault rifles and i'm
like
it looks like some dudes in an urban
environment with like short barreled
full auto some sort i can't tell what it
was
i'm like yeah that's like legit hard to
get
nfa and this is how did he get that in a
city
yeah these are guys are serious regular
law abiding citizens won't have any of
that stuff
when you look at what happens with the
proud boys these guys are like yes
officer we believe in you thank you
we'll cooperate yeah they're in prison
the lesson here is don't cooperate with
police because you're not going to get a
fair deal or at the very least
you can see how the system works if if
you show up and do the right thing and
admit
and and give the information they lock
you up they're like yep exactly
yeah and there's just been no
repercussions whatsoever for going after
these
these terrorists essentially you know
for months on end and it's just spread
like
violence never goes goes away unchecked
if if people act violently they don't
just say one day oh hey it's the 15th of
the month let's stop being violent
they actually have to be met with force
that's just that that's the law of
nature that's the way it has to go and
so we actually have to
put this back in the bottle by arresting
a lot of them and i think we started
arresting the leaders
in exposing who they were and how they
were being funded like we did with the
mafia back in the day
they a lot of the popular support that
these these groups are getting in places
like portland
um would go away because right now
they're thriving off this whole
narrative
that hey these guys are out there
fighting fascism they're fighting for
black lives
people believe this stuff people in the
suburbs of portland believe this they
donate
money they donate political support i
mean my the neighborhood i grew up in
gave almost half a million dollars to
the
bail fund that kamala harris was
promoting to bail out people that were
burning our city down
i mean that's a level of popular
indoctrination that just
amazed me that's hard to fight but uh
but you're in a republican district
we are yeah that's really interesting
just north of portland republican
and you got to win a primary that's
right you know the way i see it is
i've said in numerous videos segments
i've done over the past couple of months
like
why why bother voting for these
republicans when you empower people like
mitch mcconnell
what does he do i agree the republican
party in 2016 2016 and 2018 had the
ability to do stuff trump got in 2017.
they could have made some moves yeah we
we knew the censorship issue was going
to be a huge problem for all republicans
they did literally nothing and i'm like
uninspired lindsey graham fist bumping
kamala harris on the senate floor it's
like one inspires the same party however
if people like you get elected you know
right now i think marjory taylor green
is like one of the only fighters
yeah whether you like her or not i'm not
you know she had a bunch of
dumb stuff on facebook at one point but
she pushes back she fights in
very similar ways to many like like the
squad she's you know fantastic she's
loud she pushes back
and so i'm not saying you know if if
congress was
entirely comprised of just the clones of
margaret taylor would be a good thing
right but you need people who are not
part of the establishment
who are going to vote against the stuff
there's i look at the two parties and
there's like you know after tulsi
gabbard left them not convinced as a
good democrat anymore
yeah and i disagree with her on some
policy issues but i think she was honest
she was honest
she was trying and i look at the
republican party and i'm like maybe 10
10 republicans yeah there's a handful
need more yeah and if you can get a lot
more in maybe in 2020 uh 2022
there will be some significant changes i
bring this up because i'm thinking about
what's going on
in portland how do you get the fbi to
actually deal with these people
well you need some political power you
do the republicans will need
to control the house probably and the
senate ideally yeah
and not only that you still have to go
you still have the issue of of biden but
then you can do more committee hearings
you can do
peanut power absolutely but you'd also
needed many of those republicans to be
populist american first yeah you know
act people who are not part of the
establishment crony machine people who
actually want to see things improve
i do have a fear of encroaching
authoritarianism though one of my fears
is that
antifa has acted a fool so much people
will just say get the feds and start
blocking these people right exactly and
then you get yeah an equal and opposite
reaction which is still not a good thing
yeah i mean it has to be done right but
i think if we treat them like a
terrorist organization or like organized
crime
go after the leaders make an example out
of some of the guys that are out there
locking arms and enabling it that a lot
of it would just kind of go away
because people don't want to people
don't want to get arrested and slap for
federal terrorism charges right
you know but then there does have to be
a clear point where we bring the feds
back and i think we can also offensively
use a lot of federal funding for these
cities because ted wheeler the mayor of
portland
he's let all this happen and then kate
brown the governor and then
in washington state jay ensley he's done
the same thing with seattle i don't
think those governors and mayors deserve
a penny of federal taxpayer dollars like
we send in the feds to clean up the
antifa
and after that we're like hey until you
guys start prosecuting criminals and you
take care of all these rampant
homeless and drug issues and crime
issues like you're just not getting any
more money
sorry yeah man if we called them
terrorists if we like declared antifa
for terrorists would then
like their the mother of the leader of
the antiva that he lives at her
in her basement would she be implicated
for terrorist charges
no no no you still get due process i
mean it's still the the federal
government and then you know
the fbi and the u.s marshals going in
you know
day in court you and i find fascinating
you know people genuinely don't believe
antifa is real they don't they don't
exist
it's just it's just an idea but it's
because they watch cnn right they don't
actually read the news they don't know
these things
and so they genuinely think antifa isn't
a real thing
yep and so i see these posts on facebook
all the time where they're like it's a
meme
antifa just means anti-fascist there's
no antifa group it's not true
and then i'm like here's a list of all
the known antifa affiliates like rose
city antifa in portland literally a
group with people with leaders
with they have a website you can sign up
to join the group the group exists it's
called
there's new york city antifa there's
like salt lake city or whatever
yeah they literally just call themselves
city antifa yeah they exist they
cooperate with each other they work
when there is like if you're in between
seattle and salt lake city or whatever
they'll meet in the middle and
both groups show up absolutely but they
say it's not a real thing
right and then what happens is you get
these hearings where and i don't
understand where the republicans are to
push back on this stuff or
i don't know if they can do anything
anyway where they're like the biggest
threat in this country is white
supremacist supremacy yeah
there's 10 000 of them and that's why i
like what's like the 88
i'm sorry the adl standard at the apk no
the adl
there's like 10 000 people yeah how many
how many active antifa are there
like substantially more oh yeah we've
seen we've seen the protests across the
country there's a lot of them
now the worst offenders are a lot less
yeah
but mass protests for a year riots
smashing up windows
yeah i think that's a much bigger threat
i suppose though when they're flying
black lives matter flags at our
embassies of course to them the biggest
threat is
white supremacist white supremacy yeah
regular americans and the left has no
incentive to go after antifun blm
because they
execute their their political policy for
them and we saw that in lighting the
cities on fire
in the the year that trump was trying to
get elected and then right now the way
that they've jumped on to this whole
palestinian issue like you see the whole
palestinian flag getting flown by
antioch and that's all being done
because
joe biden is screwing up the middle east
like we gave money back to iran iran
gave money to hamas
boom we got a war going again but to run
cover for that just in the same way
antifun blm
brings up all these racial issues to
keep the working class distracted now we
have
antifa saying oh it's all about
palestinian liberation now that's part
of the black lives matter movement like
it's run distraction it's tribalism yeah
that's all it is because i i i went to
um
belfast and they have the peace wall
right from northern ireland and on one
side it's palestine on one side it's
israel
and i asked a local i was like why why
what's with the israel-palestine thing
and it's like oh you know
the the one side thinks they're
oppressed so they associate themselves
with palestine the other side
thinks that they're the you know natural
right so they israel and i'm like that
has nothing to do
with with like northern ireland and like
yeah it's just they identify it's like
leftist causes for one group
nationalist causes for the other group
and i'm like that's all it is
yep this you know and that's what i
think i think we're seeing a lot of that
here where people
are getting into fights over israel and
palestine and and i tell you man there's
a lot of people i hear them screaming
like pro-israel screaming pro-palestine
and i'm like i don't understand
like i'm hearing the same thing from
both sides i'm not here to equate i'm
just saying man people are really
tribalistically
involved in that conflict and it's
really hard to
to to figure out let's take super chats
though okay
if you have not already give a little
tap to that like button
help support the show share the show
with your friends and thanks for being
here on
memorial day i know most of you probably
wanted to you know sit back with the
grill getting the burgers going
and uh you know having your your long
weekend
thanks kamala but i guess she came out
later and you know what's funny about
that is when donald trump was like happy
memorial day you know
to all of our brave men and women who
served our economy is great and
and they were like how dare trump
minimal you know minimize memorial day
and then camel harris is like enjoy the
long weekend yeah it's like is that what
it is
it makes me sad actually man it's pretty
sad yeah i wish people were like like
you know we should have like something
happen on the tv and yeah we'll do an
event and talk about like yo this is
like serious stuff but instead it's like
we're gonna go drive to the beach
yep grill burgers yeah you know what
though um
it's a double-edged sword i suppose it's
the it's the men and women who fought
to defend this country that allowed
people to go have that long weekend
exactly
burgers on the at the lake yeah i would
watch youtube videos of um
like stories told by vietnam veterans
yeah they'd come on for like an hour or
20 minutes for sure and give
their their first person account
basically or their
you hear their third person account of
what they experienced that's what you
should do if you want to remember
that's right yeah that's right the
horror people have experienced so that
you can live this
this good life that's right let's read
some of these chats we got chad randall
he says joe what do you think of the
greater idaho plan
is uh it is the joining of most of
oregon to idaho
yeah i mean i understand why the
majority of oregon wants to leave oregon
they want to
they want to get away from all the
craziness in portland i think it just
served as a wake-up call really to
the the folks in power in oregon we have
the same thing in washington too
i mean these urban centers are
absolutely destroying their states
so i i hope it wakes them up and then
but also you know power to the people if
they want to
align with idaho then god bless them i
hope it works for them yeah
charles c says hi joe thank you for your
service any advice to those thinking of
joining
the army today yeah um do your homework
like know exactly what job you want
because recruiters their their job is to
put
a body into the military and there's a
lot of great jobs in the military
so go in there with a game plan don't
let the recruiter pick the job for you
they're like you're gonna be piloting
spaceships yeah exactly and then it's
like you're in like a simulation room
it's like you're typing on a computer
and you're pressing go and you're just
wasting your time
yep yeah i i hear a lot i've heard a lot
of stories like that from people where
it's like they they describe it in the
best way possible
and then it's like the worst iteration
of what it could be yep you know
you're gonna be going on adventures and
it's like they just put you in a remote
base somewhere it's like you're just
sitting there
all right let's see bobby bob says you
and your
uh you and your quest have helped me
find the spine to be extremely vocal on
facebook i feel so much better
those who truly care about me stayed and
those uh and those are the people i want
in my life
it's encouraged others to do the same
i'm hearing these conversations more
awesome it's partly sad though it is i
mean think about it you've got
you know the average person has like 300
friends on facebook and you post hey man
i'm concerned about this and half leave
yeah we're just polarizing ourselves we
are and people people just don't have
the ability to have discussions anymore
i mean
i grew up in portland like pretty
liberal place my parents were
conservative they used to just have
discussions with their friends and it
wasn't like
no friendships were ended yeah yeah now
it's now it's serious
where we're at now it's crazy all right
john wayne says april 2003 task force
120 ring a bell joe
yes it does says i was there with you
currently living in your district you
got my vote
all right wow cool stuff man
all right matthew reckham says i was in
dc today
and in the metro station i saw an ad to
be ready to save a life
carry narcan nasal spray the opioid
epidemic is out of control what is that
for real
that's crazy yeah wow
clay chapman says joe have you ever met
john striker meyer
i have only heard him on podcasts and
read his books yeah
legendary vietnam special forces guy oh
cool yeah
here's a good one daddy day says joe are
you pro-nuclear why or why not
like pro-nuclear power definitely
definitely pro-nuclear power
absolutely i mean because that's just
another way that we can have energy
independence and energy security
and there's a lot of fear mongering
around it from environmental groups when
it's actually the
best carbon-free carbon neutral energy
source it's ridiculous
absolutely you know i worked for
greenpeace briefly
one of the things that made me kind of
disillusioned with them i was only there
for a few months was that they were like
nuclear power is bad
and then i looked to one of the founders
of greenpeace who was like nuclear power
is an excellent way to reduce carbon
emissions and create high energy
density and i'm like what what's what do
you say
yeah like i don't understand and it just
felt so political to me
man people like nuclear afi's defense
says joe what is stopping america first
agenda from being powered by nuclear
tech
i don't think anything is yeah yeah i
still want to be energy independent with
with our oil but yeah nothing here we go
seven empire says joe i'm a fellow
refugee of portland oregon
now over the river in washul all right
ex-af security forces
regretfully and naively voted for jhb in
2020
you have my future vote thank you for
your service awesome thank you
there you go
brandon youngquist says tim i listen on
spotify i work graveyard shift and can't
listen live
i listen to every show later wanted to
say i live well below my means and more
people should adopt this lifestyle
and trevor is the worst and i miss luke
i think we reconciled with trevor though
yeah yeah yeah i think we apologize
because trevor felt bad
okay and then he came back and we were
like you're all right trevor much love
all right w couch 8 says please ask your
guest his thoughts on the defense
department screening national guard for
political bias for the inauguration
oh yeah so what's going on right now the
defense department and the whole
ideological test is absolutely
insane and very dangerous so we're
essentially making
uh our men and women in uniform take a
ideological
oath of allegiance not to the not to the
the flag and the constitution but to the
political party in power so they've gone
through and
started looking at who was aligned with
trump trump pro-trump facebook posts all
that type of stuff and gadsden flags
yeah gadsden flags
it's just absolutely crazy so and right
now they've got all the commanders in
the military running scared so that's
why you see so much like
woke virtue signaling coming out of the
uh the prominent leaders in the military
and that that that kind of stuff is
creepy because they start reassigning
people of certain ideologies they're
discouraging it and then you get a woke
military and they'll do whatever the
tribe whatever
that's right called wants praetorian
guard yeah exactly
all right e honda 420 says hey tim i
started my youtube channel about two
years ago and i've been doing a weekly
conspiracy podcast called
the gay frog chat it's funny how many
things talked about on that show come
true in that time
yeah it's a weird time to be alive man
it's a weird time
anything about tech says joe thank you
for your service what can i do as a
civilian software engineer to serve and
help serve our country
infosec robotics or what or is it not
even a good idea to attempt to
contribute under this administration
i understand because what we just talked
about with what's going on in the
military i understand the apprehension i
still
really highly encourage people to serve
in some capacity especially the tech
sector i mean we're fighting
a very heavy tech cyber war right now
mainly against china
but i think pushing for cyber security
is is absolutely essential
i think people don't realize that you
could arguably say we're in a new hot
war with china because of the cyber
conflict from happening
i mean yeah the google got hacked a
couple years ago with a very serious
breach
yeah these things are they breach the
dod i mean yeah you know
like yeah the whole uh office of
personnel management league
and we just keep keep going on now
that's not a big deal and yeah
man it's just scary stuff all right
mexican-american conservative says mr
kent we need you bro
by the way there are more gun servatives
out there than libs
they just shut our voices out on social
media it's all manipulation
very true we are the majority
tim bo says hi tim and team it's tim hey
tim how's it going
screw solar roads is a project to cover
water canals with solar
saves on evaporation and uses existing
infrastructure eh
very cool there you go that makes sense
interesting
chemical x66 says joe were you in al
assad in 2006
i was building camps for the green
berets while i was in nmcb40
here's a few bucks for a few rounds to
remember all we lost raw
seabees right on i was out there at that
time yeah i i didn't stay for very long
but yeah we were in and out of amber
robinson yeah it's kind of crazy how
many people were like were you here were
you here it's like oh man yeah i know
that you know
that's cool all right
viva frey says godspeed joe keep on
keeping on what up hey
yeah john visas i never went to college
and i'm going to cross right at 110k
this year
right now i'm hauling 20 tons of food
into a big city that wants to eliminate
the fuel i'm using to bring their food
yep yep i think that guy understands the
economy better than lots of phds
it's like a bunch of dudes building a
bridge
and they're driving across it to bring
food into the city
and the democrats are voting to chop the
bridge down
right from underneath it yeah all right
man
all right let's see where we at not
locutus
oh good for you says i live in your
district sir from one veteran to another
you can expect my vote
awesome right on thank you
eric miller says add a little facial
hair and grow your hair out and joe kent
could become jon snow
vote jon snow to take on the woke
walkers i mean white walkers
i actually had hair about as long as
yours uh for
i didn't get a haircut for two and a
half years after i got in the military
so yeah and then i cut it for
the congressional yeah got to look good
yeah the job interview got to get a tidy
up i don't know maybe up there it would
have
played well yeah it was 50 50. yeah
really yeah they're like consultants who
are like
the hair works in the pacific northwest
yeah i definitely thought about it
carry like a an axe and a saw with you
and wear like a red flannel so
yeah i'm a lumberjack i live here
all right uh jonathan warner says first
super chat my friend and brother who i
served with for six years in the
minnesota national guard
committed suicide last year oh man today
i remember joshua roland lindsay
and all my other fallen brothers and
sisters sorry to hear it man yeah
sorry but greatly appreciate you know
everything that you guys have
done it's memorial day man people need
to
you know i i say this i've been around
the world you've been in much more
serious places than i've been
but i've seen other countries and i
remember the first
the first country i ever went to outside
of the u.s it doesn't count as canada
right it doesn't really count it's
american junior then i went to spain saw
some conflict
okay spain's a different country then i
started going other places i went to
brazil i went to
turkey turkey was the next country i
went to and then i started to really
realize i'm like man america sure is
awesome america is pretty awesome and i
i would come back after spending so much
time hearing all these activists and all
these leftists talk about what their
problems with it were and like
you know the feds and all the things
they hated which they now love for some
reason anyway
i remember i think it was like after
maybe like morocco or turkey or
something come back to the us and i'm
just like oh
right like yeah and then i walk up and
like what are you doing my journalist
and boy am i glad back glad to be back
here i'm gonna go to five guys
i'm gonna get double bacon cheeseburger
but both peanuts
yep man some of these places i've been
to scary stuff
if you want to live through this stuff
we really have something special here
really changes your perspective i think
getting outside the country and getting
into a
a rougher part of the world like you can
come back to america and you're like
well a lot of places got it
and it's not just that too it's like
even going to like scandinavia
not just sweden i've been to norway and
the ideological homogeneity is also
freaky
yeah it's like everybody agrees with
everything and it's like
it's kind of weird it's like i like an
america that some guy can just you know
you can see a house with a trump flag
and a house the blm flag next to it yeah
actually i'm like that's rad
that is good no don't fight right it's
funny that people
you know we have this although it is
getting a bit extreme it is yeah
all right let's see where we where we're
at
matterhorn v says we were misled being
told we needed college in the 90s and
uh and the arts the audience that it's
called individuals need higher education
the modern world will survive with less
english majors but it won't survive
without electricians
right well you know when the market
corrects i suppose they start paying
electricians more which they probably
already do actually
yeah yeah cause it's hard it's hard to
get people to come work on your place
you know this is one of the problems
is that people get a degree in like you
know feminist dance
mm-hmm and then they're like why can't i
get a job electricians are getting paid
well
yeah just go get an apprenticeship but
they don't understand so they demand the
government regulated
brother brother bro vet says 350 000
vietnam vets
were killed by agent orange if the va
didn't hide this number would americans
still tolerate the abuse and corruption
in the pentagon and permanent political
class today
i mean they know now right is that
number accurate i'm not super familiar
i'm not sure if that number is 100
accurate
i'm not questioning him it does sound a
bit high but yeah there's definitely
been a good deal of covering up with
agent orange and now we're living
through our own crisis of the suicides
and the burn pits
like um depleted uranium i heard that
the rounds used
first iraq war 93 were like radioactive
so there's all that
all those bullets in the dust basically
because the the tanks would have
depleted uranium armor so you needed
depleted uranium rounds to penetrate
yep the the armor so then i'll just all
this radiation has caused what they
called gulf war
syndrome syndrome yep matthew reckham
says if the infrastructure bill was only
going towards infrastructure
we'd be able to put routers in a tunnel
to get internet access in our subways
that's always been crazy some subways
have it some do yeah yeah finally
navasa says each altcoin aims to solve a
different problem in the economy bitcoin
can be the gold standard equivalent
but v chain covers supply logistics etc
sure
a lot of people are always mentioning
their particular alt coins the ones they
like
and a lot of these aren't decentralized
yeah like ethereum runs on you know
amazon services
so it's more like a company's it's a
company token you know yeah
so i think there's decent investments in
a lot of them in a certain way that's
why i love crypto technology
bitcoin is truly decentralized austin
brown says
this is why crypto is the future and
elon doesn't make sense
he knows it is the future you invent
tesla and spacex without knowing crypto
is the next real deal
all these different all all these
different people the disparaging term
will turn into one two five ten fifty
one hundred
it will be every day oh i'm sorry uh
cryptos
okay we'll turn into you know one five
ten twenty is that what is that what
we're saying we'll be every day uh
sure yeah i think dogecoin actually does
has a good potential to be used as like
cash
it's two percent inflationary people
were telling me every year goes up to
two
supplies two percent increase and it's a
really fast and
efficient exchange so it actually could
work if they get some developers on it
and make the the
uh the system more robust you could
actually just swipe and boom
doge is the is the cash people tried
making bitcoin cash be the cash to
bitcoin's
gold and like might be dogecoin yeah
it's got mean potential
ap says hi i really enjoy your videos
and guests
i am transferring to uc berkeley and i
was wondering if you had any advice to
deal with crt
also do you all have opinions on right
to repair e.g apple products
i think you should have a right to
repair as for critical race theory
um you know i don't think
arguing with people who have uh
the opposite of your moral framework
will work people seem to think you know
like
we we hear antivirus doesn't exist we
see it all the time there's a guy who's
like
you know posting on twitter it's a viral
tweet like you know and and i'm like
you're not going to convince them how
you argue that yeah they know they're
lying
yeah because their moral framework is
different from yours you believe i
should be honest the best of my
abilities
they believe there's no truth but power
yeah so how do you argue with that
you can use the uh olinsky rules for
radicals and make them live up to their
own standards
so if you are uh i mean actually i don't
think your race matters because there's
a bunch of
you know white progressives who are
engaging in this the way i always say is
like look
if anyone ever tries to call you into a
meeting on diversity or whatever
the moment they mention white anything
get mad and say i'm sorry is this a
meeting
on white people like are we seriously
gonna bring everybody in here to talk
about white people again are you a white
supremacist
use their own logic against them right
if you're having a meeting
and they bring in a bunch of minorities
and start talking about white people
sounds to me like they're trying to yeah
have a meeting for white people you know
so there you go it's kind of racist and
then if they don't you can accuse them
of ignoring white supremacy so no matter
what they do that's the point of their
ideology
to wield power against anyone who
opposes them
you can do the same thing yeah i'm not
entirely convinced that's the right way
to do it but yeah maybe
fighting fire with fireworks when it's a
controlled burn how would you say not
giving your money to the university of
southern california
yeah why are you going to berkeley you
might want to go to liberty university
or
hillsdale a lot of better places i'll
give you i'll give you some advice
my advice is um you shouldn't go there
because what will happen is
you're eventually going to get a
professor who's going to say i want you
everyone needs to
write a paper on why white people are
bad yeah and then when you're like
they're not they fail you
yeah and then you just spend money for
nothing so why go at all
why not just go start a business like
i guess people on the left don't want to
do this but i played guitar at the
subway
i just started doing my thing you know
make stuff and sell stuff yeah
absolutely i made cds once played shows
and then sold the cds
we're not in the era of cds anymore yeah
but you know you can put music up
somewhere record it
with it's so easy to record music these
days you're not going to get massive
studio hollywood you know whatever
production
but your natural production i guess
that's the music place but you can
record stuff with your phone
you can get apps to help you make it
better yeah all right
jimmy kinto says i was hired to bring
back a dying business from a guy who has
an mba and couldn't make it work
i did and i asked for a raise and was
denied because i didn't have a college
education
you quit that's it yeah i worked for a
company once and they were like we want
to give you promotion but you need a
college degree and i was like i can quit
right now
and they were like uh hold on and then
the regional director was like
degree or nothing i said adios yeah they
were like
i'm like i need to work for your company
but i got hired at a company that
required a college degree it was really
simple you know what i did
i went the interview and they were like
it said i had college listed on my
resume because i went for like a month
yeah and they were like so did you
graduate i was like oh no i didn't
graduate they're like well this
job requires a college degree and i was
like i understand
yeah and they're like but you don't have
one and i was like no but if you want to
hire the person who's best for the job
well then clearly you'll hire me as my
resume clearly shows i've got the
records experiment experience but if you
want to hire someone with no experience
at all fresh out of college by all means
you can do so with my blessing
i don't need to work for you and they're
like no no you're hired yeah they were
like
he sold it nice i'm like dude if you're
not smart enough
to see that i'm better at this job and
my experience
is better than any college degree i
shouldn't i wouldn't want to work for
your company anyway
exactly and when i was in la my agent uh
was trying to get me booked
for union gigs i was non-union and you
know in order to
have to a union show you have to be in
the union they really like yes or that
your first job is a union show they'll
give you your card and you can join the
union
so he my agents and most agents would
say just put that you're in the union on
your resume
and then when you get in there if they
like you they'll hire you it doesn't
matter and that's what happened and then
you and then after what three times you
get your union yeah no the first time
they saw it and they were like well you
can defer your first one and then they
were like oh you're not in the union and
they just stamp it
put them in the union yeah all right
let's see brian
fontenot says no concern for quantum
computing breaking standard encryption
overnight
or to say kill crypto overnight there is
uh absolutely and by certain standards
by certain
news stories they might already have the
technology to break it however
there's you know i've talked to a lot of
experts about this and they say there's
always the option of a hard fork there's
always developers and decent
the decentralized network can always
repair any crypto that
if quantum computing breaks it then
we'll have to the system has to be
robust to be on just
one pitfall if quantum computing can
break it
well that's a problem but there's a lot
of things that could probably break it
51
attacks are a big threat and the market
cap for a [ __ ] for bitcoin isn't that
high
so they could have done it a long time
ago we don't know however i think most
people there's different countries
there's different financial interests
all the vested interest in preventing
the system from breaking because they've
got too much wealth tied up in it
so that's why the more these companies
invest the more confident i get in it
because
do i think you know goldman sachs is
planning on losing money in their crypto
investment
exactly i don't i think they're planning
on making money and they built you
building redundancy the system so one
hack doesn't take down
the whole thing quantum computing can
break standard encryption which would
unravel the blockchain allow for pure
manipulation yeah but i was talking to
some crypto experts who explained to me
why they weren't concerned with that at
all
they were like i can't i'm not an expert
and i couldn't explain but
that used to be a big concern for me i
was like i don't know man you know i
probably would have bought way more
bitcoin back in the day
but all the stories about quantum
supremacy these you know google's got a
quantum computer with like a ridiculous
amount of qubits
and i'm like i don't know if i want to
get involved in something that could be
overdone by new technology
and then i had a bunch of crypto experts
like explain to me why it wasn't a
concern and then i was like
i don't know exactly what you're saying
so i'm not a crypto guy but uh
you know like i'm not a cryptographer
but if the experts
you know that i know and trust are
convinced it's safe yeah
all right well i guess all you could
really do right i don't know why i would
have confidence in the dollar
i was just gonna say that yeah exactly
yeah how much how much how much more uh
shaky is that than the dollar u.s
government has guns i guess but yes yeah
china and russia have guns too right
frank sculla says hey tim and gang how
are your live events going to work
how much notice will people have and
what kind of experience can one expect
would i have enough time to drive from
texas to where you guys are at give me
details
in all likelihood the answer is yes
we'll probably
do the announcement a week in advance so
like on a monday
i don't want to say exactly on a monday
so i don't know for sure because i don't
want people just sitting there spamming
refresh to try and get tickets first
come first serve
but you know you'll get at least a
week's notice that like hey this friday
event tickets are up
and then we're going to do first come
first serve tickets then we're going to
do auction-based tickets
and so we try to balance it so that the
people who are active
and see the email notification or
whatever will just right away be like i
want to take it
we don't have a big capacity like this
is a small space so we probably can only
get like 30 people
and that might be pushing it so then the
other idea is the auction based system
so that if you're busy working and you
have the resources you can be like okay
i'll spend
x my max on a ticket and you might be in
the top 15 and you might get it
although some people might spend a
really good amount of money and i mean
it's just
we couldn't do just one or the other you
know we had to try to make it balance so
that everyone gets an opportunity
considering there's limited space
but we're working it out we want to do
this in february
we had to wait because of standard legal
business
stuff we have to fill out and paperwork
and covid made everything
not happen like you can't get paperwork
done it is ridiculous
it's starting to reopen so we're hoping
soon we'll be able to do the live event
so
it's it's like legit i was like
everywhere it's like march we're going
to do the event and then it was like
here's the paperwork you need to do it's
like okay
well i don't have that can we get this
done it's like well the offices aren't
open because of coke it's like no
okay well that's lame we'll we'll
we'll get to it though we'll get to it
all right
mr full metal towel gap full metal gets
says
hey tim and gang awesome show tonight
can you let joan know that there there
are chinese military soldiers at fort
jackson
with nipr accounts nipper accounts
yeah it's the unclassified government
system oh really
yeah i'm not sure why there would be
chinese soldiers there that's kind of
crazy
that sound real like possible no i mean
we don't do military exchanges with the
chinese that i
know of i mean we have countries that
we're friendly with will bring over and
they'll get access to some computer
systems but
i certainly hope it's not the chinese
yeah i heard they were like in canada or
something they were doing drills or
i believe they have done drills with it
with the canadians like
mostly just exchanges ceremonial stuff i
don't think they were actually doing
military maneuvers
all right let's see whoop it just jumped
on me i love when it happens
you get a big flood of super chats right
away
where are we at there we go magnificent
devil says hey tim big fan
wanted to clear up something most mature
crypto is decentralized not just bitcoin
the dev project doesn't control the
blockchain the miners or validators and
proof of stake do
but what i mean is like ethereum is on
amazon web services
say aws which means amazon could be like
by ethereum
all right let's see the ghost of teddy
roosevelt says bully for you mr kent
maybe it's time to bring back the bull
moose party
yeah there you go we got endorsed by the
or i got endorsed by the
bull moose project all right yeah that's
cool yeah
jay bond says moved to south korea to
pay off 110
okay i'm sorry 100k college debt my wife
married me knowing the amount
now we are debt free with two kids and
finally moving home awesome
there you go well done making it happen
cal ratch says stay the weekend in san
francisco and the poop thing is
definitely real
oh yeah man that's crazy because
everywhere
just so many beautiful cities just been
absolutely destroyed yeah san francisco
portland seattle just
yeah san francisco is one of the worst
places i've ever been to yeah but
it could be beautiful it was in like the
early 2000s it was beautiful i was there
uh i i did a few guest spots for
discovery yeah
so uh we did like some segments on like
nuclear weapons and stuff
and one day before i'm going in i went
to a taco
a mexican place to get food and i've got
like a hoodie on my backpack with my
computer in it cause i'm going to do
work and they completely ignored me and
so i'm just standing there like watching
the servers walk past me and i'm like
standing here so finally i'm like okay
and i just walk up into the restaurant
i'm standing there
and a woman goes do you need something
and i went uh yeah food
and she went oh oh um yeah i just have a
seat so i'm like did they think i was
like a homeless guy
that sounds like it probably i mean you
know i looked like a homeless guy yeah
but
wow that's a crazy experience i go to
new york
you know when i was working out in new
york i went to i came up with a
steakhouse it's in the columbus circle
it's like really expensive
and i'm wearing the same thing and
they're like right this way sir and
they're like
they don't care they're like you have
money by all means come on in yeah okay
san francisco they must not tolerate it
they just don't yeah
all right william hornoff says greetings
tim
you uh greetings all tim you often use
the phrase don't attribute to malice
what can be attributed to stupidity
well it's uh don't attribute to mao's
that which can be explained by
incompetence
and have to disagree stupidity implies a
lack of choice ignorance
the left and those aligned actively
choose to be malicious thoughts
so uh hanlon's razor is never a tribute
to malice that which can be explained by
incompetence so not necessarily
stupidity lack of ability lack of
you know function but uh it's not always
you know sometimes people are malicious
so you're talking about antifa and
people on the far left and all that
stuff
they're malicious yes yeah they're not
all incompetent right
a lot of democrats are incompetent yes a
lot of republicans are too
oh yeah so all right colin sanders says
hey joe
intel pog here i always liked working
with sf better than the rangers and the
seals
you guys can actually chill have a beer
is that true
that's true yeah can't confirm
all right troy dingman says
i wish my local government would have
had a flyover for the fallen today with
a bunch of aircraft from different
generations that would have been nice
that sounds really cool
all right where are we at
some people are uh
chiabo bandit says joe biden is not my
president hillary is
and she was the greatest president we've
ever had there you go
i mean the timelines are dead ender yeah
yeah okay let's see
s uh s d kakarok says just tuned in
so didn't hear the details of this
stream spent 2005 in ied
alley of west baghdad in 0708 near some
green berets in the suny triangle
joe seems like a pretty solid dude much
respect thank you
there you go i was in those areas as
well go seven-ish
yeah oh this is a really important
question gigi player says tim i'm trying
to grow a beard
but when i put my head on a pillow it
feels so itchy any advice
i'm i don't know i don't know you get
used to it yeah i don't know i guess
lay on your back it's just needed yeah
put your head on the back of the pillow
eat less salt
there you go i think i think it gets
softer if you don't eat a lot of salt
put a uh put wrap
i was gonna make a joke i'm not gonna do
it because people will take it seriously
i was gonna say take plastic wrapping
no no no no youtube is gonna be like
that was serious
no no no all right let's see
fiona is my bee ass damn soul souldate
says
mr kent i am a navy vet and hood river
native currently residing in van tucky
and baffle
all right i cannot wait to volunteer for
your campaign bless you and yours
excellent thank you run on i'm looking
forward to it very cool uh gg player
then asked again about his itchy beard
sorry i don't i don't want to tell you
man coconut oil all right let's do uh
we'll do a couple more here hot dog 400
says maybe 10 years from now your basic
phone will be more powerful
than the quantum computers today 10
years from now
i'm not entirely convinced i i don't i
don't know where we're at with quantum
computing but it needs like super
freezing temperatures i think to operate
so
but you know we'll see technology
advances all right let's see
oh whoa what's this skyler tucker says
world's largest meat processor jbs just
got hit with a cyber attack like
colonial pipeline look into it please
a meat processor you say what a strange
thing so the federal reserve got nailed
then a pipeline now a meat processor
yeah well all right we'll do one more we
got
let's see dec daniel says i lived in sf
but moved to south bay
there are needles everywhere everyone i
know has stepped in poop
and i've been chased down main street a
few times and people high off whatever
they were on lol
hello what a response yeah wow he's
patient
yeah all right my friends this has been
uh a great memorial day with all you
guys hanging out watching so thanks for
being here
you know a lot of people are probably
chilling but hey good for you it's
america and
just never forget the people who
sacrificed so that you could have your
long weekend and chill
so smash that like button don't forget
to subscribe to this channel
uh did i say hit the like button i did
hit it again no wait don't hit it twice
hit it once or three times but not twice
you can follow the show
facebook.com timcast irl and share our
video clips there
and on instagram uh at timcasterl you
can follow me personally at tim cast
we're live monday the friday pm we're
back tomorrow is there anything you
wanted to mention specifically uh of
your campaign website or yeah absolutely
contributions yeah people want to
support us
they can go to joe kent for congress.com
they can read about all my stances on
the issues there
link treat all my social medias on there
as well and if they can
i'd really appreciate a donation so i'm
up against the republican establishment
dollars and the democrat establishment
dollars so
fighting for the america first agenda so
anything they can contribute i'd really
appreciate i put up
200 000 of my own dollars into my
campaign just to kind of put my money
where my mouth is
so five ten fifteen dollars will help me
help help take this country back
best of luck yeah thank you you can also
follow me in crossland.net and ian
crossland
across all social media thank you guys
so much for coming i was listening to
ben shapiro talk about some of these
heroes these stories
these guys did incredible things and i'm
so happy to have an actual veteran with
us here on memorial day
and you guys can follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlidge as i attempt
to surpass sourpatch kids and followers
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com for an exclusive
bonus segment so make sure you go there
and sign up become a member help support
our work
and thanks for hanging out we'll see you
all there bye guys
you